ALLEN ARCHULETA. BATES BELL
GORGEOUS BRADFORD COUNTY AT ALL
CHIANG DALLY DODD THE RUSSELL
DOES JOHNNY GLAZER GONZALEZ
GROVE HERTZBERG HILL. HUESO
TADO JACKSON JONES LEYVA
MCGUIRE MITCHELL MONNING MORE
LOCK THE REAL NIELSEN PAN
PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO SKINNER
STERN STONE NUMBER WHY COUNTY
WIENER WILK. COLLEAGUES WE HAVE
A QUORUM QUORUM IS PRESENT
WOULD DIE THE MEMBERS AND OUR
GUESTS BE ON THE RAIL AND IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE. WE
WILL BE IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY OUR GUEST CHAPLAIN
THE SISTER BRIGID MCCARTHY VICE
PRESIDENT OF MISSION
INTEGRATION DIGNITY HEALTH
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING AND WE WILL BE LED IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. TO
THE FLAG BY OUR NEWLY WED
SENATOR LENA GONZALEZ. THANK
YOU. OUR PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON
IS FROM THE COLUMBAN FATHERS
WHO SERVE BECAUSE PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD. LOVING
GOD. WE BELIEVE YOU LIVE AMONG
US. AND THE PLACE WHERE YOU ARE
IS HOLY GROUND. WE KNOW YOU
LOVE ALL PEOPLES AND THAT THEIR
WAYS AND LANDS ARE ALSO HOLY.
HELP US TO DISCOVER ALL THE
WONDERS OF THEIR FAITH THEIR
LIVES AND THEIR STORIES. SEND
US YOUR HOLY SPIRIT. AND HE
WILL LISTEN. AND LEARN AND MEET
YOU ON HOLY GROUND A MAN. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
ONE INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY.
ALL THEY CONSIST. COLLEAGUES WE
WILL MOVE TO PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR. AND WE'LL START WITH
SENATOR DOLLY. UNDER PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR AND BELIEVE YOU
HAVE SOME INTRODUCTIONS TO MAKE.
SENATOR DOLLY THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT GLAD TO KICK IT OFF
HERE THIS MORNING ALWAYS A
PLEASURE THIS YEAR MARKS THE
TWENTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
FORCED FOUNDATION A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT EDUCATES
CALIFORNIANS ON THE IMPORTANCE
OF SUSTAINABLE FORCED TO
PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT AND
GROW THE ECONOMY FOR THE PAST
TWO DECADES MANY MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE HAVE
ATTENDED THE FOUNDATION'S
ANNUAL EDUCATION FOR STORES. TO
OUT SHOUT IN THE NORTH COAST TO
LEARN FIRST HAND THE IMPORTANCE
IS OF SUSTAINABLE FOREST
PRACTICES. BEYOND THE CAPITAL
THE FORCE FOUNDATION KEEPS
CALIFORNIA KIDS CONNECTED TO
THE POOREST WITH FREE SCIENCE
CURRICULUM. IN CLASSROOM
PRESENTATIONS AND A ONE ACRE
DEMONSTRATION FORCED AT CAL
EXPO. THE DEADLY WILDFIRES OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS HAVE
BEEN DEVASTATING FOR MANY
CALIFORNIANS WITH THE LOSS OF A
PROPERTY AND LIFE HOMES
BUSINESSES AND ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES. HEALTHY RESILIENT
FOREST ARE THE CREEK ARE
CRITICAL TO THE PREVENTION AND
RECOVERY FROM THE CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES THAT IS WHY IT IS
ESSENTIAL THE CALIFORNIANS HAVE
ACCESS TO THE SCIENCE BASED
INFORMATION ON SUSTAINABLE
FOREST. THAT THE FORCE
FOUNDATION PROVIDES I'D LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE BRENDA WASHY BRENDA
WASHINGTON DAVIS CHAIRPERSON
MARK LUSTER PAST CHAIRMAN RICH
INGLE BOARD MEMBER AND A GARY
UP WERE MISSING ONE HE'S IN
FLIGHT GEHRY RIGHT NEAR SIN.
AND JANE TABOR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR PLEAT MEMBERS PLEASE
JOIN ME IN GET INTO GRADUALLY
THEM ON TWENTY YEAR ANNIVERSARY
OF THE FORCE FOUNDATION. PEOPLE
HELPING OF THE STATE OR POOREST
THANK YOU SENATOR DOLLY
. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR VERY
IMPORTANT WORK AND NEXT UP. WE
HAVE SENATOR WIENER WHO WILL
PRESENT A RESOLUTION TO THE
OUTGOING CLASS OF SCIENCE
FELLOWS SENATOR WIENER. AT THE
PRO TEM'S DESK. I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I MATTER PRESIDENT
I'M NOT MAKING THIS
PRESENTATION TODAY ON BEHALF OF
CENTER LEYVA WHO I KNOW WHICH
IS THIS YOU COULD BE HERE SO I
COLLEAGUES I'M HONORED IF YOU
MOMENTS TO RECOGNIZE OUR TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY FELLOWS ON EVERY
YEAR PC'S SCIENTISTS AND
ENGINEERS FROM ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY I COME HERE TO SPEND A
YEAR IN SACRAMENTO WORKING IN
THE LEGISLATURE IN OFFICES FOR
COMMITTEES WHERE THEY HELP
CRAFT LEGISLATION AND THEY GOT
A FRONT ROW SEAT. TO SEE THE
INNER WORKINGS OF POLICY MAKING.
HELLO PROGRAM IS HIGHLY
COMPETITIVE IT IS UNIQUE THERE
IS NOTHING LIKE THAT AND THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY. EACH YEAR
THE FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM ATTRACTS
THE BEST AND BRIGHTEST. FROM
TOP UNIVERSITIES ALL OVER AND
THIS YEAR IS NO EXCEPTION. BY
THE FOLLOWING CALIFORNIA
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY FELLOWS
HAVE SPENT THE PAST NINE MONTHS
ANALYZING LEGISLATION FISCAL
PROPOSALS. AND SHARING THEIR
TOP NOTCH SKILLS AND KNOWLEDGE
WITH US. I KNOW I TAKE A MOMENT
TO HONOR THEIR PUBLIC SERVICE.
I'M GOING TO BEGIN WITH DOCTOR
SIDNEY CHAMBERLAIN. DR
CHAMBERLIN IS WITH THIS SENATE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
pIN PHYSICS FROM THE UNIVERSITY
OF WISCONSIN MILWAUKEE INTO
RESEARCH SHE CONTRIBUTED TO THE
FIRST DETECTION OF
GRAVITATIONAL WAVES TINY COSMIC
RIPPLES THAT CARRY VITAL
INFORMATION ABOUT THE CONTENTS
AND EVOLUTION OF THE UNIVERSE.
I SERVED AS A POSTDOCTORAL I
PENN STATE UNIVERSITY SHE ALSO
HOLDS BASSAR SCIENCE DEGREES IN
PHYSICS AND MATH FROM UTAH
STATE UNIVERSITY. BY IN THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER CITY
ANALYZE AND BRIEF STAFF OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON
TWENTY DIFFERENT BILLS THAT
WERE IN THAT COMMITTEE IN
ADDITION CITY STAFF CENTER
STORE. ON THE STATE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEE
CONGRATULATIONS.
CONGRATULATIONS. TO SIGN SCHOOL.
PERHAPS THE NEXT MACARTHUR
GENIUS AWARD WINNER. GRADUATION
SENATOR WIENER. THANK YOU SO
NEXT WE HAVE DR CHANEL MAD ME
WITH THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE DR MANNY RECEIVED A
PHD IN NEUROSCIENCE FROM JOHNS
HOPKINS SCHOOL OF MEDICINE HER
RESEARCH EXAMINE THE WAY THAT
BRAIN CELLS ARE LINKED TOGETHER
TO FORM CIRCUITS THAT PROCESS
INFORMATION. I SHE ALSO
RECEIVED A BACHELOR OF SCIENCE
IN EUROPE. SEE OF TEXAS AT
DALLAS IN THIS SHE WORKED ON
BILLS TO HELP COLLEGIATE
ATHLETES AND FOSTER YOU US HELP
TO HELP STUDENTS UNDERSTAND THE
RAGE REGARDING SEXUAL
HARASSMENT TO HELP FORMER
STUDENTS TO CHANGE THEIR NAME
AND OR GENDER ON SCHOOL RECORDS
TO ENGAGE STUDENTS IN CIVIC
ACTIVITIES TO IMPROVE STUDENT
HEALTH AND TO CREATE A
COMPREHENSIVE STATEWIDE STUDENT
DATA SYSTEM. BOB HONEST
PROFESSIONALISM ENABLED HER TO
NEGOTIATE ACTS PLATE WITH A
DIVERSE CROSS SECTION OF
ADVOCATES CONGRADULATIONS
CONGRATULATIONS TO DOCTOR MARK.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR HELP. GOOD
WORK. SENATOR WIENER THANK YOU
NOW CLOSE TO MY HEART WE HAVE
DOCTOR WAS OUT FOR AS TO AS
WITH THE SENATE HOUSING
COMMITTEE WAS AND THE HONOR OF
SHARING THE STAFF RECEIVE HER.
SEE AN ORGANIC CHEMISTRY FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE OVERSEAS STUDY THE
INTERACTIONS OF MOLECULES ON
SYNTHETIC SELL SERVICES I
SHELVE THE STADIUM LONG BEACH
CITY COLLEGE BEFORE OBTAINING
HER BOXERS SCIENCE IN
BIOCHEMISTRY FROM THE CSU LONG
BEACH. FOR THE PAST YEAR SHE'S
HELPED THE SENATE HOUSING
COMMITTEE AND IDOLIZING TEN
BILLS FOR THE COMMITTEE
COVERING A WIDE RANGE OF ISSUES
INCLUDING BUILDING STANDARDS
MOBILE HOMES HOMELESSNESS AND
VETERANS HOUSING INCLUDING
PROPOSING AMENDMENTS TO MY OWN
BILLS SO IT TAKES A CERTAIN
LEVEL OF. SELF CONFIDENCE TO DO
THAT WHICH IS GREAT AND IT MADE
THE BILL BETTER BUILT SHE ALSO
HELPED THE STAFF LEGISLATION
THAT I'M OFFERING TO ENABLE A
DREAM IS AN OTHER I IMMIGRANTS
TO SERVE AN OFFICIAL POSITIONS
AND THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
PARTY. SHE'S PASSIONATE ABOUT
HELPING CONNECT YOUNG PEOPLE OF
COLOR WITH THE HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM THAT IS ALREADY BEEN
WORKING. ON NUMEROUS OUT REACH
IDEAS CONGRATULATE.
APPALACHIANS THANKS TALK. THANK
YOU SENATOR WINNER HEY. RIGHT
NEXT MADAM PRESIDENT IS DR
SAMANTHA TO CHEAT WITH THE
SENATE STANDING COMMITTEE ON
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT SAMANTHA
EARNED A PHD IN BIOMEDICAL
ENGINEERING. FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA DAVIS
HER RESEARCH EXPORT METHODS FOR
ENHANCING CHEMO THERAPY FOR
PANCREATIC CANCER BY COMBINING
NOVEL NOT A TECHNOLOGIES WITH
ULTRASOUND. I SAMANTHA ALSO
RECEIVE A DOCTORS OF SCIENCE IN
BIOMEDICAL ENGINEERING FROM
CASE WESTERN UNITS RESERVE
UNIVERSITY IN CLEVELAND OVER
THE PAST YEAR SHE'S HELP THE
COMMITTEE BY TAKING INITIATIVE
AMID STAFFING SHORTAGES. ON THE
COMMITTEE QUICKLY BECOMING AN
EXPERT ON CANNABIS ADVERTISING
AND SECURITY GUARDS TRADE
OFFICE IS IN ARMENIA THE
PHARMACY TECHNICIAN RATIOS
ALWAYS A FUN ONE INDUSTRIAL
HEMP AND TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY. AT
ALL TIMES SAMANTHA PROVIDED
NUMEROUS CONTRIBUTION TO THE
COMMITTEE THIS LINE AND SITE
CURIOSITY AND GRACE AND I KNOW
THAT THE COMMITTEE DEEPLY
APPRECIATES HER TREMENDOUS
KNOWLEDGE AND SKILLS.
CONGRATULATIONS TO DOCTOR TO.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST WE HAVE
DOCTOR WALTERS BY WHO WORKED
WITH THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ERIC
STUDY MICROBIOLOGY THROUGHOUT
HIS ACADEMIC CAREER EARNING A
PHD IN MICROBIOLOGY FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA DAVIS
HIS RESEARCH HAS RANGED FROM
SUSTAINABLE BIO FUELS TO THE
HUMAN PARASITE GIRARDI. USING
WITH AN INTERESTING CONNECTING
HIS RESEARCH THE BROADER
IMPACTS BEYOND THE LABORATORY
BURKE ALSO RECEIVED A BACHELOR
OF SCIENCE IN MICROBIOLOGY FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF WISCONSIN
MADISON. THROUGHOUT HIS
FELLOWSHIP ERIC PREPARED
ANALYSES FOR OVER A DOZEN BILLS
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE ON A WIDE
RANGE OF TOPICS INCLUDING
CLIMATE CHANGE AIR QUALITY
PESTICIDES HAZARDOUS WASTE AND
ENERGY EFFICIENCY. HE ALSO
WORKED IN TWO HIGH PROFILE.
THERE A BILL TO BAN THE USE OF
THE PESTICIDE AND TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANT. CLICK HERE FOR US
ADDED BILLS. UNDER HIS BELT OUT.
HE ALSO WORKED IN TWO HIGH
PROFILE EXCUSE ME AND ALSO A
BILL TO EXPAND THE PROHIBITION
OF SECOND GENERATION
ANTICOAGULANT WITH THAT DECIDES
CONGRATULATIONS. COLLEAGUES.
THE WALLS AND FLOOR FOR.
DOCTORS WHO ARE GOING TO HELP
TO DIRECT THE FUTURE. THANK YOU
SIR WINNER. AND THEY WILL HAVE
A PHOTO WITH ALL OF THEM IN ANY
MEMBERS WHO'D LIKE TO JOIN IN
.
THE THIRD TIME. CONGRATULATIONS
AND THANK YOU FOR HELPING US
WITH GOOD. NEXT WE ARE GOING TO
ASK SENATOR HUESO. TO STEP
FORWARD HE HAS A RESOLUTION OF
THIS IS FILE ITEM TWENTY EIGHT
COLLEAGUES S. C. R. FIFTY SEVEN
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR HUESO
RELATIVE TO THE FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF SPECIAL
OLYMPICS. SENATOR HUESO. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
SENATORS TODAY I'M VERY PROUD
TO PRESENT S. C. R. FIFTY SEVEN
RESOLUTION TO COMMEMORATE THE
FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
SPECIAL OLYMPICS. FOR FIFTY
YEARS THE SPECIAL OLYMPICS HAS
TRANSFORM LIVES THROUGH THE JOY
OF SPORT EVERY DAY EVERYWHERE
IN NINETEEN SIXTY TWO EUNICE
KENNEDY SHRIVER SELFLESSLY
STARTED A SUMMER CAMP FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE THE INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES IN WASHINGTON DC.
AFTER YIELDING MUCH SUCCESS THE
PROMISING PREMISE ROUTE
INVOLVED THROUGHOUT THROUGHOUT
THE NINETEEN SIXTIES
CULMINATING IN THE FIRST
SPECIAL OLYMPICS COMPETITION
HELD AT SOLDIER FIELD IN
CHICAGO ILLINOIS IS ON JULY OF
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT. JUST A
YEAR LATER NINETY SIX NINE
RAFER JOHNSON FOUNDED SPECIAL
OLYMPICS CALIFORNIA AND IN JULY
OF THAT YEAR THE WESTERN
REGIONAL SPECIAL OLYMPICS WERE
HELD AT THE LOS ANGELES
MEMORIAL COLISEUM WITH OVER
NINE HUNDRED ATHLETES
REPRESENTING TWENTY COUNTRIES
FROM THE WESTERN UNITED STATES.
IN NINETEEN NINETY FIVE THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL LYMPICS
DIVIDED INTO TWO CHAPTERS
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA GIVING EACH
CHAPTER THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GREATLY EXPAND OUTREACH EFFORTS
MORE RECENTLY IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
THE SPECIAL OLYMPICS WORLD
SUMMER GAMES WAS HELD IN LOS
ANGELES WHERE HOSTED OVER SIX
THOUSAND ATHLETES FROM A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE
COUNTRIES TAKING PART. IN
COMPETITIONS IN TWENTY FIVE
SPORTS THE SPECIAL SPECIAL
OLYMPICS HAS GROWN FOR THE
WORLD'S LARGEST SPORTS
ORGANIZATIONS FOR PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES
BOASTING OVER FOUR POINT FOUR
MILLION ATHLETES IN A HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY COUNTRIES. MEMBERS.
THE SPECIAL OLYMPICS IS NOT
JUST AN ORGANIZATION IT'S AN
EVER GROWING GLOBAL AND SOCIAL
MOVEMENT THROUGH THE POWER OF
SPORTS PEOPLE WITHIN TO
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES
DISCOVER NEW STRAINS AND
ABILITIES SKILLS AND SUCCESS.
NOT TO MENTION THEIR OWN
PERSONAL HAPPINESS THESE
ATHLETES ALSO INSPIRE PEOPLE IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND AROUND
THE WORLD TO OPEN THEIR HEARTS
TO A WIDER WORLD. OF HUMAN
TALENTS AND POTENTIAL I AM
PROUD TO STAND BY THE SPECIAL
OLYMPICS FOR THE FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CELEBRATING A SUCCESSFUL ONE
HUNDREDTH. ANNIVERSARY. MEMBERS
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR SCR
FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU SENATOR
HUESO TOURNEY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM ANY
DEBATE OR DISCUSS. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE BILL FIVE LARGEST. I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CHIANG I
DALY AYE DODD HI THERE ALSO I
GALGIANI I GLAZER. BY GONZALEZ
I GROWTH I HERTZBERG AYE HILL
AYE HUESO. I TADO I JACKSON I
JONES I LEYVA. MCGUIRE BY
MITCHELL. BY MORNING I'M MORE
LOCK I'M REAL. HI NIELSEN AYE
PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH BY
RUBIO. I SKINNER. I STERN I
STONE. I AM BURKE BOB I COUNTY
I WINNER BY WILK. LOOK AYE AYES
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED SENATOR
HUESO FOR PURPOSE MADAM
PRESIDENT TO MAKE AN
INTRODUCTION WITHOUT OBJECTION.
IN CONJUNCTION WITH THIS
RESOLUTION MADAM PRESIDENT I
HAVE HERE OF REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE SPECIAL OLYMPICS THAT
HAVE COME FROM DIFFERENT PARTS
OF THE STATE TO COME TO THE
SENATE FLOOR HERE THIS YEAR
WITH US HERE WITH ME TODAY I
HAVE REPRESENTATIVES FROM BOTH.
SPECIAL OLYMPICS SOUTHERN AND
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. AMANDA
BAHMAN IS A SENIOR MANAGEMENT
OF DEVELOPMENT WITH THE SPECIAL
OLYMPICS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
SAM BLAKE IS A GLOBAL MESSENGER
WITH THE SPECIAL OLYMPICS FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. ALYSSA
KESSLER IS THE CHIEF OPERATING
OFFICER WITH THE SPECIAL
OLYMPICS IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND JONATHAN SPARKS IS A GLOBAL
MESSENGER WITH THE SPECIAL
OLYMPICS NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
PLEASE HELP ME GIVE THEM A WARM
WELCOME CALLING SO WARM WARM
WELCOME. POSSIBLE
. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR. SEEING NONE WE WILL
CENTER PORTANTINO. EXCUSE ME
CENTER PORTANTINO OF MY
APOLOGIES FROM THE PRO TEM'S
DESK THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR
THANK YOU AMANDA PRESIDENTE
MEMBERS IT'S MY HONOR TODAY TO
HAVE THE ENTIRE BOARD OF THE
ARMENIAN NATIONAL COMMITTEE
WESTERN REGION IN CHAMBERS THE
ARMENIAN NATIONAL COMMITTEE OF
AMERICA IS THE LARGEST
GRASSROOTS ARMENIAN
ORGANIZATION IN THE COUNTRY AND
WE TODAY WE HAVE NOT ONLY THE
ENTIRE BOARD BUT WE HAVE THEIR
CHAIR NOR ASEFI ON AND THEY'RE
VICE CHAIR RAFI QASSAB IN IN
THE BACK. AND I'D LIKE TO GIVE
A WARM SENATE WELCOME TO THE
ARMENIAN NATIONALLY SO WARM
WELCOME PLACE TO OUR. ARMENIAN
NATIONAL COMMITTEE BOARD
MEMBERS
. SENATOR CABALLERO
UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES IF WE COULD GIVE OUR
ATTENTION PLEASE TO SENATOR
CAFIERO WE AREN'T PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR THANK YOU MATTER
MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON
CALL YOU COLLEAGUES IT'S MY
PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE TO YOU
THE CALIFORNIA FARM WORKER
FOUNDATION LIKE WHEN THIS YEAR
THE COMPASS YOU KNOW THE
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE SOMEBODY
SAID THAT. I WANNA THIS
ORGANIZATION IS DEDICATED.
POWERING FARMWORKERS TO BECOME
EFFECTIVE ADVOCATES FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR COMMUNITY
THEY OFFER SERVICES SUCH AS
IMMIGRATION CLINICS. WILL
WOMEN'S SELF DEFENSE WORKSHOPS
FINANCIAL WELLNESS WORKSHOPS
AND FITNESS CLASSES HEALTH
EDUCATION CLASSES ENGLISH
LEARNING CLASSES AND MUCH MORE.
THEY DURING THISTODAY TO GAIN
FURTHER INSIGHT INTO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS INVITE
AVENUES FOR WHICH THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO BENEFIT SOCIETY
COLLEAGUES PLEASE HELP ME TO
WELCOME THEM TO THE CAT TO THE
CAPITAL. AND TO SHOW US OUR
SHOW THEM OUR BEST BEHAVIOR
MANY OF US CAPITA YOU. LOTS A
LUCK BUT PLEASE. A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE TO THIS WONDERFUL
ORGANIZATION. ARE THERE ANY
OTHER PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
SEEING NONE WE WILL MOVE ON NOW
TO MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
WILL BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES
FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE
DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. PURSUANT TO SENATE
RULE TWENTY NINE POINT TO THE
TEN SUBDIVISION DE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS ARE REFERRED TO
THE RULES COMMITTEE FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN SB ONE TWENTY EIGHT.
THERE ARE FLOOR AMENDMENTS AT
THE DESK THEY WILL BE DEEMED
ADOPTED. SENATOR HILL THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT PLEASE
REPRIEVES MOVE FILE ITEM NINETY
FOUR A. B. TWELVE NINETY NINE
TO THE INACTIVE FILE AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR THERE
WILL BE NOTED THANK YOU SENATE
BILL ANY OTHER ITEMS UNDER
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
SEEING NONE. A SENATOR
HERTZBERG MY APOLOGY SIR. THANK
YOU AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE MOVE FILE ITEM
ONE SIXTY EIGHT A. B. SIX OH
NINE BY LEVINE TO THE INACTIVE
FILE. THAT WILL BE CHAU NOTED.
COLLEAGUES WE WILL NOW MOVE
MOVE TO CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE THE SECOND READING
FILED MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN OH
NINE SIX TWENTY FOUR AND
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE SEVENTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER
SECRETARY NOW UNDER UNFINISHED
BUSINESS. COLLEAGUES WE'RE
GOING TO WORK ON OUR UNFINISHED
BUSINESS SENATE THIRD AND
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING TODAY WE
WILL BE GOING FOR WE HOPE A
COUPLE HOURS OR SO TO TRY TO
CLEAR UP WE'VE GOT ABOUT SIXTY
FIVE BILLS THAT WE CAN TAKE UP
TODAY IN A INDICATIONS FROM
COLLEAGUES AT THAT IS THERE AND
TAX SO WE'RE GOING TO START NOW
WITH THE CONCURRENCE IN
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENT STARTING
WITH FILE ITEM. FOURTEEN FILE
ITEM FOURTEEN SENATOR CAFIERO
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 527% OF THE COMING
YEAR AND ACT REALLY INTO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. CENTER CABALLERO
THANK YOU BETTER PRESIDENT IN
MEMBERS SB FIVE TWENTY SEVEN IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW CANNABIS AND
INDUSTRIAL HEMP CULTIVATORS TO
RECEIVE THE SAME PROPERTY TAX
ASSESSMENTS. UNDER THE
WILLIAMSON ACT THE MAN THE
AMERICANS ARE TECHNICAL IN
NATURE THEY CLARIFIED THAT
INDUSTRIAL IS AN AGRICULTURAL
COMMODITY THANK YOU AND I
EXPECT THE ASK DR. THIRTY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NON MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
BATES BELL BY PORGES. BRADFORD
I CAMBIADO I CHIANG HI DALY AYE
DODD HI THERE ALSO I GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER I GONZALEZ BY GROWTH.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
FOR TITLE. JACKSON NO JONES NO
LEYVA. MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL HI
MONNING I'M MORE LUCK. HIGH
MORALE NO NIELSEN NO PAN I
PORTANTINO I ROTH. HI RUBIO AYE
SKINNER AYE STERN BY STONE NO
NUMBER OUR CASKEY. BY WINNER BY
WILK HI. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BATES NO PURCHASE. GROW
FOR NO WITH SO I TITLE. LEYVA.
OUR EYES THIRTY KNOWS SEVEN
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM FIFTEEN SENATOR BATES. IF
YOU WISH TO TAKE UP THAT ITEM.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY ONE BY SENATOR BATES
RELATIVE TO THE COSTA MESA FIRE
CAPTAIN MICHAEL CHRISM MEMORIAL
HIGHWAY SENATOR BATES THANK YOU
AYE MAN PRESIDENT MEMBERS I
ESSIE OUR TWENTY ONE AND BATH
FOR CONCURRENCE THE AMENDMENTS
ADDED CO AUTHOR CHANGE LOCATION
OF THE HIGHWAY NAMING. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES BY BILL I BRIDGES. I
BRADFORD I KELLY AT ALL I
CHIANG AYE DALY AYE DODD BY THE
RISE OF I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH. I
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO HI
TITLE. BY JACKSON HI I JONES.
BY LEYVA MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL I
MONNING. I'M MORE LUCK I'M A
REAL BY NELSON. PAN HI
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
SKINNER BY STERN BY STONE. BY
HAMBURG IA CATHY I WINNER HI
WILK HI. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS LEYVA NIELSEN. HI GUYS
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION EXCUSE ME ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN SENATOR PAM
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE FORTY THREE
BY SENATOR PAN ANAK RELATED
HEALTH CARE SENATOR PAN THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS SP
THREE FORTY THREE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THIS BILL REMOVES
PROVISIONS IN THE LAW THAT
ALLOW KAISER PERMANENTE EIGHT
REPORT LESS INFORMATION TO
REGULATORS AND OTHER HEALTH
PLANS AND HOSPITALS. MINUTES
WERE TAKEN ASSEMBLY TO RESPOND
SPECIFICALLY CONCERNS RAISED BY
KAISER BY DOING TWO THINGS ONE
REINSTATING THE ABILITY OF
KAISER TO REPORT ON A GROUP
BASIS THE ANNUAL BALANCE SHEET
DETAILING ASSETS AND
LIABILITIES AND THE ANNUAL
STATEMENT OF CASH FLOWS. ENDS
TO REQUIRING US BUT TO REQUIRE
TO ADOPT REGULATIONS BY JULY
FIRST TWENTY ONE DAUGHTER
PERMIT KAISER REPORTS SOME OF
THE DATA REQUIRED IN THE ANNUAL
REPORT ON AN INDIVIDUAL
FACILITY BASIS AND THE ANNUAL
BALANCE SHEET AND STATEMENT
ACTUALLY IS ON A GROUP BASIS.
UNTIL THE ADOPTEES ELATION
AMENDMENTS PERMIT KAISER TO
CONTINUE SEPARATING THE ENTIRE
REPORT ON A GROUP BASIS OUR OF
THESE A MENACING PLEASE MOVE
THE OPPOSITE KAISER AS THEY'RE
STILL RECORDING AT THE LAY ON
THE RECORD WITH THE FILES MALL
PER QUARTER REPORTS ON A GROUP
BASIS AT THE ASPEN AUTOMATES
REPORTING. ALL THESE AGREE THAT
THE AMENDMENT TO READY TAKE IT
WITH THE ADMINISTRATOR CAN
KAISER'S ABLE TO COMPLY WITH
ALL THE PREDICTIONS OF BILLS I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR I AM
CONCURRENCE ON ASSEMBLY MINUTES.
THANK YOU SENATOR PENN DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM IS
THERE'S ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA I HAD CAN STE HI
BATES NO BILL HI PORGES NO
BRADFORD I CAPITAL I CHIANG NO
DALY NO DODD. HI THERE ALSO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER BY GONZALEZ
BY GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG I HILL
AYE HUESO BUY PER TITLE I
JACKSON I JONES NO LEYVA
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL AYE MONNING
I'M MORE LOCK NO MORALE NO
NIELSEN NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO I
ROTH AYE RUBIO. I SKINNER BY
STERN I STONE NOVEMBER. POWER
CASKEY I WINNER BY WILK HI. I
TWENTY NINE KNOWS TEN ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CAN CURTAIN FILE
ITEM TWENTY ONE SENATOR
BRADFORD. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL FIVE
THIRTY FOUR BY SENATOR BRADFORD
AND ACT REALLY INTO INSURANCE
SENATOR BREATH THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND SB FIVE THREE
FOURS PACKING CONCURRENCE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND MADE MINOR
CORRECTIONS TO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR INSURANCE FOR INSURERS AN
INSURANCE HOLDING COMPANY TO
SUBMIT THEIR SURVEY OF DATA FOR
SINGLE FOR IN A SINGLE FILING.
THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED BY OUR
FORMER COLLEAGUE COMMISSIONER
RICARDO LARA AND THEN SUPPORT
BY OUR OUR WIDE ARRAY OF
ORGANIZATION I RESPECT WHAT
THREE AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER BRADFORD DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION MANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THE SIDE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES I BILL FIVE LARGEST
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CHIANG
HI DALY. DOT HI THERE ALSO I
GALGIANI. BY GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI
HILL. I WAS SO BY HER TITLE I
JACKSON HI I JONES. BY LEYVA
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL BY MORNING
I'M MORE LUCK MORRELL NIELSEN.
PAN AYE PORTANTINO I ROTH BY
RUBIO. I SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE. NUMBER HI MY COUNTY.
WIENER. BY WILK HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS BURGESS.
DALY GROVE. LEYVA MORLOCK
MERRELL NIELSEN. STONE WHAT
CASKEY. HI ICE THIRTY TWO NO
ZERO ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN COLLEGE WE ARE NOW
GOING TO MOVE O SENATE THIRD
READING WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH FILE ITEM TWENTY FIVE BY
SENATOR GROWTH. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SEC ACRE
RESOLUTION FIFTY FOUR BUS
UNDERGROWTH RELATIVE TO GOLD
STAR MOTHERS AND FAMILIES DAY
SENATOR GROWTH THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT GOOD MORNING A
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE SINCE TO
PRESENT ESSIE FIFTY S. C. R.
FIFTY FOUR. ESSERE FIFTY FOUR
COMMEMORATE SEPTEMBER TWENTY
NINTH TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN
IS GOLD STAR MOTHERS AND
FAMILIES STATE WE HONOR THE
SERVICE OF OUR IN THE DUTY OF
VETERANS WE MUST ALSO HONOR THE
SACRIFICE AND COMMITMENT OF THE
MILITARY FAMILIES THAT SUPPORT
THEM AS THEY GO OFF TO WAR. THE
GOLD STAR MONSTER NATIONWIDE.
THAT GAVE IT ALL FOR THIS
COUNTRY AND THEIR FAMILY. THEY
HAVE DEDICATED THEMSELVES TO
LIFTING UP OTHER MOTHERS OF
FALLEN SOLDIERS AND HELPING
THEM DEAL WITH LIFE OF THE
AFTER THE LOSS OF THEIR LOVED
ONES. THE GOLD STAR MOMS TRACER
RIPS BUT BACK TO GRACE DARLING
SEYBOLD A MOTHER WHO LOST HER
SON DURING WORLD WAR ONE AND
THEY SAID SHE SOUGHT TO CHANNEL
HER GRIEF INTO THE SERVICE FOR
OTHER MOMS AND VETERANS. GREECE
FOUNDED GOLD STAR MOTHERS
SHORTLY AFTER WORLD WAR ONE IN
AN EFFORT TO PROMOTE A SENSE OF
COMMUNITY AMONGST THOSE MOMS
NOW ISOLATED AND SUBJECTED TO
IMMENSE GRIEF UPON THE DEATHS
OF THEIR CHILDREN. WELL GRACE
IS FOCUS WAS CENTERED ON
SELFLESS TASK OF EIGHTEEN OTHER
MOMS AND FALLEN VETERAN SHE
NEVER WAVERED FROM THE SERVICE
OF. SERVING VETERANS THAT SPENT
LONG DON TEEN DAYS OF RECOVERY
IN THE HOSPITAL. GREECE'S
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE GOLD STAR
MOTHERS ORGANIZATION HELP TO
EXPAND THEIR REACH OF SERVICE.
EVEN AFTER EXPERIENCING THE AN
FOR MATT AND FERMENTABLE GRIEF
OF LOSING A CHILD. OR MULTIPLE
CHILDREN GRACE AND HER GOLD
STAR MOTHERS SERVE TO TEEN YOU
TO SERVE OUR COUNTRY THROUGH
THE CARE OF INJURED VETERANS.
THE TERM GOLD STAR FAMILY CAME
FROM. WORLD WAR TWO. JUST AT
WORLD WAR TWO WAS STRICTLY A
FILL OVER PHILLY EIGHTY WITH
GOLD STAR MOTHERS ORGANIZATION
BUT EXPANDED TO INCORPORATE ANY
FAMILY MEMBER OF A FALLEN
SOLDIER. THESE FAMILIES WERE
DEFINED AND BY HANGING AT THE
SERVICE FLAGS AND DISPLAYING A
BLUE STAR FOR EVERY LEFT ONE
CURRENTLY IN SERVICE. AND A
GOLD STAR OUTSIDE THEIR HOUSE
FOR ONE THAT HAD FALLEN IN
SERVICE. FEDERALLY GOLD STAR
MOTHERS DAY IS BEEN OBSERVED
ANNUALLY ON THE LAST DAY OF
SEPTEMBER IN NIGHT SINCE
NINETEEN THIRTY SIX. BOTH
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA AND
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP FURTHER
THIS TRADITION WITH AN ANNUAL
PARK ATION DESIGNATING THE LAST
SUNDAY OF SEPTEMBER AS GOLD
STAR MOTHERS AND FAMILIES
STATE. WE AS A COUNTRY WILL
NEVER FORGET AND ALWAYS BE
INDEBTED TO THE MEN AND WOMEN
WHO SERVE AND CONTINUE TO SERVE
THIS GREAT NATION. THROUGH THE
ARMED FORCES AS A VETERAN I'M
ALSO PROVIED FOR APPRECIATIVE
OF THE GOLD STAR MOTHERS
ORGANIZATION AND GOLD STAR
FAMILIES AT REMAIN COMMITTED TO
SERVING VETERANS. HOSPITALS AND
OTHER MOTHERS IN FAMILIES
STRUGGLING WITH THE LOSS OF
THEIR LOVED ONES PLEASE JOIN ME
IN HONORING GOLD STAR FAMILIES
AND THEIR LOVED ONES AND I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE ON S.
YOUR FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU
SENATOR GROVE DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SENATOR ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE TODAY AS CHAIR OF THE-
VETERANS COMMITTEE IN THE
SUPPORT OF S. C. R. FIFTY FOUR
AND WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING. THIS MEASURE
FORWARD. I AM ALSO HONORED TO
BE THE CO CHAIR OF THIS MEASURE
AND TO RECOGNIZE THE FAMILIES
OF OUR FALLEN. SOLDIERS WHO
HAVE MADE SUCH A TREMENDOUS
SACRIFICE ON BEHALF OF OUR
COUNTRY. THESE GOLD STAR
FAMILIES DESERVE OUR RESPECT
OUR SUPPORT OUR DEEPEST
GRATITUDE WE MUST CONTINUE. TO
WORK AND TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES THAT HELP THESE
FAMILIES AND JUST FOR THE LOSS
OF THE LOVED ONES WHO GAVE SO
MUCH TO RESPECT AND HONOR THEIR
SERVICE AND SACRIFICE THEIR
FELLOW MEMBERS OF THE ARMED
FORCES ALSO FEEL THE SAME WAY
AND FOR THIS REASON. I'D LIKE
TO SHARE A PERSONAL STORY. JUST
RECENTLY WE HEARD ABOUT THOSE
GREEN BERETS WHO WERE KILLED IN
AFGHANISTAN. MY SON ALSO SERVES
AS A GREEN BERET AND HE HAD THE
DUTY. A FEW MONTHS BACK TO COME
HOME WITH THE WITH THE FALLEN
IN THE CASKET. IN A COMPANY
THAT CASKET ALL THE WAY HOME.
NOT ONLY THAT HE WAS ASSIGNED
TO THE FAMILY TO BE THERE WITH
THEM AS A FELLOW CAPTAIN A
FELLOW GREEN BERET AND HIS JOB
OVER THE LAST FOUR MONTHS
BEFORE HE WENT BACK TO HIS DUTY
STATION WITH THE BE WITH THE
FAMILY EACH AND EVERY SINGLE
DAY. SO HE ASSURED ME THAT THE
MILITARY IS THERE WHEN ONE OF
OUR MEN OR WOMEN GO DOWN HE
ASSURED ME THAT THEY WOULD NOT
BE FORGOTTEN IN ALL BRANCHES OF
SERVICE WHEN ONE GOES DOWN ONE
IS PARTICULARLY ASSIGNED TO THE
FAMILY. AND TO TAKE THE VALLEY
BIRD THIS GATE THE WOMAN WHO
NOW. BE A LOST HER HUSBAND. OF
TWENTY NINE YEARS OLD. AND SO
MY SON HAD TO ACCOMPANY TO OUR-
COUNSELING SESSIONS AT HOWEVER.
GO TO POST IN AND THE SIGN ALL
THE DOCUMENTS THAT ARE
NECESSARY. TO GO ACTUALLY
ARLINGTON NATIONAL CEMETERY FOR
THE FINAL BARRIER. IT WAS A SAD
SAD TIME IN MY SON'S LIFE BUT
MORE SO FOR THE FAMILY AND ALL
THE FAMILY MEMBERS WHO WERE
STILL CRYING TO THIS DAY. SO
THIS IS WHY WE HAVE TO TAKE
TIME OUT TO HONOR A GOLD STAR
MOTHERS BECAUSE THEY'VE LOST
SUCH A TREASURE. AND FOR THE
REASONS I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
BOOK. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR ARCHULETA ANY FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SING IN-HEARING ON SENATOR GROVE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT YOU KNOW AS A
MOM I CAN EVEN EVER IMAGINE
LOSING ONE OF MY KIDS I KNOW
THAT THAT WOULD BE VERY
DIFFICULT FOR ANY PERSON TO
LOSE ANY FAMILY MEMBER. AND
EVEN TO HAVE THEM SERVE.
OVERSEAS IN BATTLE TO PROTECT
THIS NATION AND THEY LOSE THEIR
LIFE AND- I DON'T SEE THAT THAT
WOULD MITIGATE ANY OF THAT
GRIEF SO I JUST ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION. AND
LET US HONOR OUR GOLD STAR
FAMILIES. THANK YOU SENATOR.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED AS HER
ANY OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTING
ARE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SING
IN HEARING NON ICE THIRTY FOUR
NINE KNOWS MEASURE SHE'S ME
VICE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. WHO ON NOW TO
FILE ITEM TWENTY NINE SENATOR
SKINNER. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SIXTY THREE BY
SENATOR SKINNER RELATIVE TO
OVARIAN CANCER AWARENESS MONTH
OF TWENTY NINETEEN SENATOR
SKINNER. THANK YOU ARE MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. S. C. R.
SIXTY THREE PROCLAIM SEPTEMBER
TWENTY NINETEEN AS OVARIAN
CANCER AWARENESS MONTH. AND
THIS CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
RAISES AWARENESS ABOUT A DEADLY
DISEASE THAT UNFORTUNATELY IS
COMMONLY NOT DETECTED UNTIL THE
WOMAN WHO HAS IT IS IN STAGE
FOR THREE OR FOUR WHICH OFTEN I.
CREATES A CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE
THE OUTCOME IS NOT GOOD AND THE
TREATMENTS ARE NOT EFFECTIVE.
MY OWN SISTER WHO WAS A
VETERINARIAN SO WAS NOT DEVOID
OF MEDICAL KNOWLEDGE WAS
EXPERIENCING A VARIETY OF
SYMPTOMS THAT ONE IT'S NOT LIKE
THERE'S A CLEAR SET OF OVARIAN
CANCER SYMPTOMS SHE WAS HAVING
THINGS THAT HER DOCTOR THOUGHT
WERE PERHAPS RELATED TO
DIGESTIVE PROBLEMS OR ANY OTHER
NUMBER OF THINGS AND SHE HAD
BEEN GOING TO A DOCTOR TO DEAL
WITH THOSE SYMPTOMS FOR OVER A
YEAR BEFORE SHE WAS PROPERLY
TESTED AND FOUND TO HAVE A VERY
AND CANCER BUT FR WHICH WAS
ALREADY STAGE FOUR. SO I THINK
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT THING
FOR US TO HAVE ALL WOMEN AWARE
OF MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS TO DO
BETTER DETECTION ON BECAUSE WE
HAVE ABOUT FOURTEEN THOUSAND
WOMEN A YEAR IN THE US THE DIE
FROM THIS DISEASE AND WHEN IT
IS DETECTED EARLIER THE CHANCES
FOR RECOVERY ARE FAR GREATER SO
I ASK YOU TO JOIN ME IN VOTING
YES. ON C. R. SIXTY THREE.
SKINNER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM SENATOR GLAZERS. I
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I KNOW THIS RESOLUTION
CHOICE BROAD SUPPORT ON THE
FLOOR BUT IT DOES GIVE ME AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT MY
MOTHER CAROL RUTH DO VENN WHO
PASSED AWAY OF A VERY AND
CANCER AND SO IN HER HONOR
TODAY I THANK THE AUTHOR AND
WILL. PLEASED ABOUT AS FOR THE
RESOLUTION. THANK YOU SENATOR
GLAZER ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
SKINNER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZE
DISCERNING OBJECTION TO USING
OUR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL SEEING
AND HEARING ON ICE THIRTY NINE
NO ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED MOVING ON NOW TO FILE
ITEM. THIRTY SENATOR DODD
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE THREE
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SIXTY FIVE A SENATOR DODD
RELATIVE TO CHILD PASSENGER
SAFETY WEEK SENATOR DOT THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS
TODAY I'M PROUD TO PRESENT S.
C. ARTS SIXTY FIVE WHICH WOULD
DECLARE THE THIRD WEEK OF
SEPTEMBER IS CHILD PASSENGER.
SAFETY WEEK AUTOMOBILE
COLLISIONS ARE A LEADING CAUSE
OF UNINTENTIONAL DEATH IN
CHILDREN TAKING THE LIVES OF
OVER FIFTY CALIFORNIA USE EVERY
YEAR RESEARCH SHOWS THAT OVER
70% OF CHILDREN WHO LOST THEIR
LIVES IN THESE ACCIDENTS WHAT
IS SURVIVED IF THEY'D BEEN
PROPERLY RESTRAINED IN THEIR
SAFETY SEATS. CHILD PASSENGER
SAFETY WEEK WOULD ENCOURAGE LAW
ENFORCEMENT HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS CHILD ADVOCATES
PARENTS AND GUARDIANS TO
PROTECT OUR CHILDREN BY
ENSURING THEY ARE PROPERLY
RESTRAINED IN THE CORRECT SEAT
FOR THEIR AGE AND SIZE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THIS SEE OUR SIXTY FIVE.
THANK YOU SENATOR DARDIS THIRTY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
IS THIRTY OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING ARE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING AND HEARING ON ICE
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THIS
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MOVING ON
NOW TO FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE.
SENATOR GONZALEZ YOU PREPARED
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION FIFTY SIX BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ RELATIVE TO
WOMEN'S EQUALITY DAY. CENTER
GONZALEZ THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND SENATORS ON
BEHALF OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS I
AM PLEASED TO PRESENT S. R.
FIFTY SIX COMMEMORATING AUGUST
TWENTY SIX TWENTY NINETEEN AS
WOMEN'S EQUALITY DAY IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY WE COMMEMORATE
THE NINETY NINTH ANNIVERSARY OF
THE RATIFICATION OF THE
NINETEENTH AMENDMENT WHICH WAS
ADDED TO THE U. S.
CONSTITUTION. ON THIS DAY
NINETEEN TWENTY AND THE
HISTORIC IMPORTANCE TO WOMEN'S
RIGHTS INCLUDING THE BATTLE TO
ATTAIN THOSE RATES AS A LATINA
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
WHILE WE'RE CELEBRATING NINETY
NINE YEARS OF THE WOMEN'S RIGHT
TO VOTE WOMEN OF COLOR STILL
FACE MANY CHALLENGES THAT KEPT
THEM FROM EXERCISING THEIR
RIGHTS AND WE'RE NOT ABLE TO
VOTE. UNTIL MANY YEARS LATER
IT'S TIME TO RECOGNIZE WOMEN
THE ALSO WORK HARD FOR THEIR
OWN VOTING STRUGGLES LONG AFTER
THE NINETEENTH AMENDMENT WAS
RATIFIED IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE
FORTUNATE TO HAVE ONE OF IF NOT
THE LARGEST WOMEN'S CAUCUS IN
THE NATION AND A HISTORIC
THIRTY SEVEN ELECTED WOMEN
SERVING IN OUR LEGISLATURE BUT
WE STILL HAVE A LOT MORE WORK
TO DO. DESPITE OUR EFFORTS IN
POLICY GENDER EQUALITY ANY
QUALITY EXCUSE ME PERSIST MANY
AREAS WOMEN'S EARNINGS ARE
STILL FAR TOO LOW COMPARED TO
MEN'S IN CALIFORNIA AND WOMEN
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY EMPLOYED
IN JOBS. THAT PAY THE MINIMUM
WAGE. WOMEN ARE CRITICAL TO IS
STRONG AND VIBRANT CALIFORNIA
AND WE MUST CONTINUE TO FIGHT
UNTIL WE CLOSE THE GAPS. IN
EDUCATION THE WORKPLACE AND
ACHIEVE FAIR PAY AN EQUAL JOB
OPPORTUNITIES. LET THIS SERVE
AS A CELEBRATION OF HOW FAR
WE'VE COME AND SERVE AS A
REMINDER THAT WE MUST CONTINUE
THE FIGHT UNTIL WE'RE TRULY
EQUAL. I APPLAUD MY COLLEAGUES
ALL OF THE WOMEN THAT WORK.
WITH ME EVERY TODAY WEARING
WHITE AND I ALSO. A MALE
COLLEAGUES FOR ALSO JOINING IN
THIS AS WELL AND WEARING WHITE
TO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE SENATE
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR SENATOR
JACKSON'S. YES THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I RISE ON BEHALF OF
THE JEWISH CAUCUS MY JEWISH
COLLEAGUE. COLLEAGUES
RECOGNIZED WAS PROBABLY SMART
TO HAVE THEIR- BOBBY. THE
JEWISH GRANDMOTHER SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
THEY'RE VERY SMART GROUP AND OF
COURSE. THEY KNOW WHICH SIDE
THEIR MUCH HAS BROUGHT THE
BUTTERED ON. SO I RISE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATIVE
JEWISH CAUCUS IN COMMEMORATION
OF WOMEN'S EQUALITY DAY THIS IS
THE NINETY NINTH ANNIVERSARY OF
THE RATIFICATION OF THE
NINETEENTH AMENDMENT AND
THROUGHOUT THIS YEAR WE WILL BE
CELEBRATING NOTING
ACKNOWLEDGING AND FIGHTING. TO
CONTINUE OUR EFFORTS TO GAIN
EQUALITY FOR WOMEN PERHAPS EVEN
THIS YEAR WE WILL RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF PASSING THE BALL
RIGHTS AMENDMENTS WE ARE
FRANKLY ONE STATE AWAY. I IT IS
OUR HOPE THAT UP. WE SEE LEVELS
OF A QUALITY AS WERE MENTIONED
BY MY GOOD COLLEAGUE AND SEAT
MATE WE ARE MAKING PROGRESS AND
I THINK YOU NOTED THAT FOR THE
FIVE SCIENTISTS THE DOCTOR TO.
MEMBERS SO FAR SENATE A INTERN
PROGRAM WERE WOMEN WE ARE
SEEING MORE MORE WOMEN ENTERING
THE WORKFORCE AND HIGHER AND
HIGHER LEVELS AND IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT THIS
52% OF THE POPULATION THE
APPROPRIATELY RECOGNIZED AND
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITIES TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. BUT ON THE
ANNIVERSARY OF THIS IMPORTANT
DATE I DOUBT MANY OF YOU WILL
BE SURPRISED TO HEAR THAT THERE
WERE A NUMBER OF JEWISH WOMEN
IN THE UNITED STATES TO. AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE TWENTIETH
CENTURY OBJECTED TO THEIR
EXCLUSION FROM THE FRANCHISE
AND WE'RE WILLING TO MAKE SOME
NOISE ABOUT IT. WE ARE NOT A
PLACID DEMOGRAPHIC AFTER ALL.
THE ONE MOVEMENT FOR WOMEN'S
SUFFRAGE WAS INTERNATIONALLY
JEWISH WOMEN WERE RIGHT THERE.
FOUNDED IN NINETEEN TWELVE FOR
EXAMPLE THE JEWISH LEAGUE FOR
WOMEN'S SUFFRAGE FOUGHT FOR
WOMEN'S RIGHTS TO VOTE IN
ENGLAND. RECEIVE HER SCHWIMMER
ORGANIZED THE HUNGARIAN
FEMINIST ASSOCIATION WHICH
HELPED ACHIEVE WOMEN'S SUFFRAGE
AND HUNGRY IN NINETEEN TWENTY.
ROSA MANOS WAS ACTIVE IN THE
DUTCH BRANCH OF THE
INTERNATIONAL WOMEN'S SUFFRAGE
ALLIANCE AND BERTHA SOLOMON
HELP WOMEN OBTAIN THE VOTE IN
SOUTH AFRICA IN NINETEEN
THIRTY. AND THE STORY OF THE
RATIFICATION OF THE NINETEENTH
AMENDMENT HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES ALSO HAS A JEWISH TWIST
TO IT. CONGRESS PASSED THE
AMENDMENT TO NINETEEN NINETEEN.
AND BY THE SUMMER OF NINETEEN
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE STATES HAD
RATIFIED THE AMENDMENT ONE MORE
WAS NEEDED TO REACH THE THREE
QUARTER THE THREE FOURTHS VOTE
REQUIREMENT. FOR THE
CONSTITUTION. EIGHT STATES HAD
WRITTEN TO THE AMENDMENT AND
FIVE HAD NOT VOTE. PROPONENTS
SAW TENNESSEE. AS THE BEST BET
TO BE THE STATE TO PUT THE
AMENDMENT OVER THE TOP. NOW THE
TEN TENNESSEE SENATE EASILY
PASSED THE AMENDMENT BUT IT WAS
DEADLOCKED IN THE HOUSE. HARRY
T. BURN THE YOUNGEST MEMBER OF
THE TENNESSEE HOUSE HAD VOTED
TO TABLE THE RESOLUTION AND
THEN AT LEAST SO THE LEGEND
GOES. A JEWISH SUFFRAGETTE I
NEED A PULITZER WHO THEN WOULD
GO ON TO BE FOLK SINGER PETE
SEEGER SAUNTERED AYE SEVEN
FIGURE OUT HOW THAT. HAPPENED
BUT WAS AT ONE POINT PETE
SEEGER'S ON'T. ARE CONVINCED
HIM TO CHANGE HIS VOTE WE DON'T
KNOW QUITE WHAT SHE THREATENED
HIM WITH BUT APPARENTLY IT WAS
EFFECTIVE AND HE DID INDEED
CHANGES VOTE. BUT AS NOTED WE
STILL HAVEN'T ACHIEVED EQUALITY
WE ARE STILL FIGHTING HARD FOR
IT WE ARE MAKING GREAT PROGRESS
AND THINGS ARE HAPPENING FROM
EQUAL PAY TO WOMEN ON CORPORATE
BOARDS TO ALL SORTS OF THINGS
WE'RE TRYING TO DO TO GIVE
WOMEN. THE SAME OPPORTUNITY BUT
WHEN WILL WE ACHIEVE QUALITY
ARE GOOD JEWISH COLLEAGUE AND
FRIEND AND VETERANS GROUP
BETTER GINSBURG WAS PASSED. HER
RESPONSE WAS SIMPLE. WHEN THERE
ARE. NINE WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATE
JACKSON WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO GO
TO CENTER DRAWS AND IN TURN THE
FLOOR OVER TO SENATOR CHAIN
CENTER DR. THANK YOU. ON
WOMEN'S EQUALITY DAY WE
CELEBRATE THE ANNIVERSARY OF
THE NINETEENTH AMENDMENT WHICH
GAVE MOST WOMEN THE RIGHT TO
VOTE. THE NINETEENTH AMENDMENT
WAS RATIFIED NINETEEN TWENTY
AND WAS MERRIN TO GUARANTEE ALL
WOMEN THE RIGHT TO VOTE. BUT
WOMEN OF COLOR WHO FOUGHT AND
ADVOCATED FOR THAT GUARANTEE
WE'RE NOT FULLY GRANTED THAT
RIGHT UNTIL NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE.
TODAY WE CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR
EQUALITY. WOMEN'S EQUALITY DAY
IS MUCH MORE A SYMBOL OF
WOMEN'S CONTINUED FIGHT FOR
EQUAL RIGHTS. EQUALITY CAN'T
WAIT. AND THE PROGRESS THAT WE
ARE MAKING AND I WOULD SAY IS
NOT GREAT PROGRESS. I AM VERY
PROUD OF OUR FIGHT. TO REACH
EQUALITY BUT THE TRUTH IS THAT
WE DON'T MAKE ENOUGH PROGRESS
EVERY SINGLE DAY THANK YOU AND
I SUPPORT THIS. THANK YOU MAN
CENTER CENTER CHIANG THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON COLLEAGUES I RISE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF S. C. R.
FIFTY SIX AS CO CHAIR OF THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE API CAUCUS.
TO HONOR AND COMMEMORATE THE
FIGHT FOR WOMEN'S EQUALITY IN
AMERICA CELEBRATING THE NINETY
NINTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
RATIFICATION OF THE NINETEENTH
AMENDMENT IS AN IMPORTANT
REMINDER OF HOW MUCH WORK WE
STILL HAVE TO DO. AS THE SOLE
ASIAN AMERICAN FEMALE MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE I
CAN ATTEST TO THIS. AND ALSO
GIVEN MY OWN CRAZY EXPERIENCES.
IT DEMONSTRATES THAT WE HAVE A
LONG WAY TO GO ESPECIALLY WHEN
IT COMES TO DOUBLE STANDARDS
AND TRULY QUALITY I MEAN I
EXPERIENCES EVERY DAY AS I'M
SURE ALL OF YOU. DO AS WELL.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WOMEN MAKE
UP 50% OF THE POPULATION BUT
ONLY MAKE UP 30% OF THE
LEGISLATURE. DESPITE THE
NUMBERS WE HAVE MADE A GREAT
IMPACT ON POLICIES THAT IMPACT
WOMEN CHILDREN AND FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THE MORE WOMEN
WE SEE ELECTED OFFICE THE MORE
YOUNG WOMEN AND GIRLS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA ARE
REMINDED THAT THEY MAY ONE DAY
SERVE IN ELECTED OFFICE.
REGARDLESS OF PARTISAN POLITICS
WHICH ENCOURAGE AND SUPPORT
WOMEN WHO HAVE A DESIRE TO BE
THE CHANGE THEY WANT TO SEE IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES. AND
RECOGNIZING TODAY AS WOMEN'S
EQUALITY DAY LET US TAKE A
MOMENT TO REFLECT ON THE FIGHT
THAT IT HAS TAKEN TO GET HERE
AND TAKE NOTE OF THE CHALLENGES
AHEAD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH CENTER MEMBERS IS THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR. FINAL CALL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CENTER
GONZALEZ WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU ALL COLLEAGUES
FOR YOUR WORDS OF ENCOURAGEMENT
AND INSPIRATION AND I ASK
RESPECTFULLY FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SEE SECTOR
CAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES AYE BILL I PURCHASED AYE
BRADFORD. I CABALLERO I CHIANG
I DALY I DODD. HI THERE ALSO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER BY GONZALEZ
I GROW. I HERTZBERG AYE HILL
AYE HUESO. BY TITLE I JACKSON I
JONES I LEYVA. MCGUIRE HI
MITCHELL. I HAD THE MONEY. I'M
MORE LUCK I'M REAL I NIELSEN.
HI PAM I PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE AYE AMBERG OUR CASKEY. HI
WIENER AYE WILK HI HI. FIVE
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED MEMBERS WE NOW WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO ADVANCE TO
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. WOULD
LIKE TO BE A TO PROVIDE THE
PRESIDING OFFICER A PRIVILEGE
TO BE ABLE TO ADVANCE THREE
DIFFERENT BILLS WE'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO ADVANCE FILE ITEM
THIRTY ONE THIRTY EIGHT. FILE
ITEM ONE EIGHTY FOUR IN FILE
ITEM TO FORTY ONE. THE BILL TO
KICK US OFF CENTER JACKSON HE
PREPARED TO PRESENT SHE IS
MISTER SECRETARY. CAN YOU
PLEASE READ FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY EIGHT. ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT HUNDRED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO AN ACT RELATING TO
CIVIL ACTIONS. CENTER JACKSON
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT I APPRECIATE
THE INDULGENCE OF THE BODY TO
ALLOW ME TO PRESENT. OF
HOPEFULLY THREE ITEMS THAT ARE
FAIRLY BRIEF. I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB EIGHTEEN EXCUSE ME
EIGHT HUNDRED WHICH IS A BILL
TO ALLOW PARTICIPANTS. IN THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S SAFE AT
HOME PROGRAM. THE FILE COURT
DOCUMENTS AS JANE OR JOHN DOE.
THE SAFE AT HOME PROGRAM ALLOWS
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
STALKING AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
TO USE THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
ADDRESS ON THEIR PUBLIC RECORDS
IN ORDER TO PREVENT POTENTIAL
ASSAILANTS FROM FINDING THEM.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS MEASURE IS
TO ALLOW PROGRAMPARTICIPANTS
TO PROTECT THEIR
CONFIDENTIALITY WALL FILING
COURT MATTERS WITHOUT FEAR
THEIR PARTICIPATION WILL RESULT
IN THE PARTICIPANTS THEIR
PARTICIPANTS NAME APPEARING ON
A PUBLIC COURT RECORDS. AND
THUS REVEALING THEIR
WHEREABOUTS THE AUTHORS WORK
WITH OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS THE
WORKABILITY QUESTIONS THAT WERE
RAISED AND IS CRAFTED THIS BILL
IT'S NOW A NARROWLY TAILORED
BILL WITH THIS WHICH WILL
EXTEND THE SAFETY NET. OF
PRIVACY OFFERED IN THE SAFE AT
HOME PROGRAM AND GIVE
PARTICIPANTS BACK THE RIGHT SO
MANY OF US TAKE FOR GRANTED
WHICH IS TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THEIR DAY IN COURT. THIS
MEASURES ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS
WITHOUT A SINGLE NO VOTE
INCLUDING IN MY- THE COMMITTEE
I CHAIR WE'RE PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY AND ALSO I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SENATOR MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. CENTER MORLOCK GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON MR
PRESIDENT JUST A QUICK QUESTION
FOR THE. FLOOR MANAGER SENATE
JACKSON WOULD YOU ACCEPT THE
QUESTION. SHE WILL CENTER MORE
LIKE PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT TAP. THERE ARE
SEVERAL ORGANIZATIONS THAT
WE'RE REQUESTING AMENDMENTS AS
SO I'M JUST CURIOUS FOR THOSE
AMENDMENTS ACCEPTED I BELIEVE
ALL THE AMENDMENTS WERE
ACCEPTED THEY WERE I KNOW THAT
THE LAND TITLE COMPANIES HAD
CONCERNS WE'VE TRIED TO NARAL
THOSE DOWN. WORKING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA JUDGES ASSOCIATION
BUT WE HAVE NARROWED IT DOWN AS
CLOSELY AS WE CAN TO AVOID
AGAIN THIS INFORMATION WHEN ON
AN INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS BEEN
STALKED OR HARASSED OR THE
VICTIM OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
NEEDS ARE FOR HERSELF OR
HIMSELF TO BE ABLE TO GO INTO
COURT TO REDRESS WHATEVER
GRIEVANCE OR CERTAIN THEY HAVE
THE IS THE FACT THAT THEY WOULD
THEN HAVE USED THEIR OWN IT.
ALLOWS THEM TO BE SEARCHED AND
INFORMATION TO BE GLEANED BY
THAT STALKER SO WE HAVE TRIED
TO EXPAND AND PROTECT. THEIR
NAMES BY NARROWING THE
CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER WHICH THEY
CAN DO THAT THERE IS THE
POSSIBILITY IF I UNDERSTAND
THIS CORRECTLY THAT AT SOME
POINT THAT NAME THAT
INFORMATION COULD BE KNOWN BUT
NOT IN THE PRELIMINARY ASPECTS
OF A PROCEEDING WHERE AN
INDIVIDUAL COULD JUST SIMPLY GO
ONLINE AND FIND THE NAME OF THE
PERSON THAT THEY ARE STOCKING.
BUT THE ESCROW ASSOCIATION IS
STILL OPPOSED. UNLESS AMENDED
LET ME CHECK HERE. I BELIEVE
THAT MIGHT MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT. THE JUDGES ASSOCIATION
AND TRADITIONAL COUNCIL WERE
BROUGHT THIS ISSUE UP THEY
UNDERSTOOD WHAT WAS BEING DONE
IN THE BILL IN THE USE OF
PSEUDONYMS WE HAVE BEEN ADVISED
THAT THEY UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERNS AND WOULD NOT BE
WORKING THE BILL SO I SUSPECT
THAT THEY ARE TECHNICALLY
OPPOSED BUT UNDERSTAND THAT
WE'RE SORT OF IN A BIT OF A
CONUNDRUM HERE. BUT THEY'RE NOT
WORKING ACTIVELY IT TO OPPOSE
THE BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH I THINK IT'S
MORE LOCKED. IN THE CENTER
JACKSON MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE FLOOR. CENTER MORALE.
GOOD AFTERNOON SIR WELL GOOD
AFTERNOON TO YOU GOOD TO SEE. A
ONE QUICK QUESTION BEFORE MANY
THIRD CENTER JACKSON WOULD YOU
ACCEPT YEAH I JUST WANT TO HAVE
IT REPAIRED AS WELL TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE CENTER WITHOUT
WITHOUT. CONCERN YEAH I JUST
CLARITY ON THE TITLE HE HAD
ASKED THAT QUESTION BUT I
WASN'T SURE OF THE TITLE. IN
THE US WILL COMPANY HAD REMOVED
THEIR OPPOSITION JUST DUE TO
THE FACT THAT YEARS OF MY LIFE
BACK THIRTY PLUS YEARS AGO. I
WAS IN THE TITLE BUSINESS AND I
KNOW HOW THAT CAN REALLY MESS
UP RECORDINGS AND- IF PEOPLE GO
TO SELL THEIR HOME. IT IT IT IT
IT'S KIND OF AN UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE DOWN THE LINE BUT
DID THEY REMOVE THEIR
OPPOSITION I DO NOT BELIEVE
THEY HAVE BUT I MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THEY WORK WITH
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL IN THE
JUDGES ASSOCIATION. AND THEN.
WE CAME OR THEY CAME AS CLOSE
AS THEY COULD. WHICH IS NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO QUITE GET
THERE I KNOW THAT THE TITLE
OFFICERS WANTED. ALL COURT
ORDERS TO BE PUBLICLY ISSUED. A
AND THAT IS THE CONCERN THAT
THIS BILL TRIES TO ADDRESS OKAY
THANK YOU YEAH. THANK YOU SO
MUCH GENERAL. BUT IS ANGELA
SENATE ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. XENON WE LIKE TO HAVE
CENTER JACKSON CLOSE YES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YOU KNOW THERE
ARE SITUATIONS WHERE YOU CAN'T
QUITE GET TO WHERE YOU HAVE
EVERYBODY IN SAYING THIS BILL
GETS AS CLOSE AS IT CAN
RECOGNIZING. THE CONCERNS THAT
EXIST IN A COURT PROCEEDING BUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF PROTECTING
VICTIMS OF THESE ARE. TIMES
WHETHER IT'S HUMAN TRAFFICKING
OR WHAT HAVE YOU SO THAT THEY
ARE. ABLE TO SEEKREDRESS WHEN
THEY NEED TO GO TO COURT
WITHOUT FEAR THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO BE STALKED BY THEIR- ABUSER
AND THIS IS OF COURSE AS WE
KNOW A SERIOUS PROBLEM. WE'VE
NARROWED THE BILL'S BEEN KNOWER
TO AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE A WHILE
PROTECTING THE RIGHTS OF THOSE
INNOCENT FOLKS WHO ARE BEING
STALKED. HARASSED ABUSED AND
PHYSICALLY THREATENED BY A
PEOPLE WHO SIMPLY CAN'T STOP
MISBEHAVING SO WITH THAT I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
INFO THANK YOU SENATOR MISTER
SPECTER. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES I BILL I PURCHASED
BRADFORD. HI KELLY YELLOW I
CHIANG. HI DALY I DODD. HI
THERE ALSO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER. BY GONZALEZ I GROWTH I
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO. I
HER TITLE I JACKSON I JONES. HI
LEYVA MCGUIRE HI I'M MITCHELL.
I MONNING I'M MORE LUCK. WE'RE
REAL. NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH BY RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN I STONE. I AM
BURKE I WOULD COUNTY I WINNER
HI WILK HI. MISTER SECRETARY
KEEP PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONCE BURGESS. LEYVA
MORLOCK BY MORRELL. HIGHS
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
PRIVILEGE OF THE PRESIDING
OFFICER WE'RE GONNA BE MOVING
ON TO ONE EIGHTY FOUR FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY FOUR SHE'S PREPARED
TO PRESENT MISTER SECTOR CAN
YOU PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN TWENTY BY THE ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND ACT
REALLY TO PERSONAL RIGHTS
WELCOME BACK CENTER JACKSON
THANK YOU THIS IS A MUCH
SHORTER BILL IT'S THE ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. COMMITTEE
BILL CLARIFIES EXISTING LAW BY
EXPRESSLY AUTHORIZING THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING TO BRING AN ACTION TO
ENFORCE FEDERAL FEDERAL ANTI
DISCRIMINATION LAWS WHEN
AUTHORIZED TO DO SO BY FEDERAL
LAW. THE BILL IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE WITH AMENDMENTS
THAT ADDRESS CHAPTER RING OUT
ISSUES AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. HEARING SEEN NINE
THIS IS WE COULD MOVE FORWARD
WITH THIS BILL WITH UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING UTILIZING
OUR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
HEARING SEEN NINE EYES THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE MOVING ON TO
THE FILE ITEM THE PROVIDING
PRESIDING OFFICER FILE ITEM TO
FORTY ONE. MISTER SECRETARY CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL EXCUSE
ME CAN YOU PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN
BY THE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AN ACT CLING TO STATE
GOVERNMENT. SENATE JACKSON
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
FREQUENTLY THE ROAD LEGISLATURE
REQUIRES VERY STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES TO SUBMIT LEGISLATIVE
REPORTS TO ENSURE THAT THIS
BODY CAN CONDUCT EFFECTIVE
OVERSIGHT. HOWEVER IF BILLS
THAT AUTHORIZED THESE REPORTS
DO INCLUDE AUTOMATICALLY SUNSET
PROVISIONS THE REQUIREMENTS CAN
STILL LINGER IN THE CODES AND
THE REPORTS CANNOT LIVE THEIR
USEFULNESS ACCORDINGLY THIS
BILL FROM THE ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE PROPOSES TO
ELIMINATE SEVERAL OBSOLETE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS. THERE
WERE ENACTED NEARLY A DECADE
AGO ADDITIONAL MEASURES. THE
ELECTRONIC SUBMISSION OF
SEVERAL REPORTS TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEES AND
FINALLY THE BILL STREAMLINES
THE SUBMISSION TIMELINE OF TWO
REPORTS SUBMITTED BY THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL RELATED TO THE
COLLECTION OF FINES AND FEES TO
ENSURE THAT THE REPORTS CAN BE
SUBMITTED AT THE SAME TIME.
THUS SAVING STAFF TIME IN
PRINTING COSTS FOR THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL THIS BORING NON
CONTROVERSIAL MEASURE IS
FOCUSED UPON CODE CLEANUP AND
GOVERNMENT EFFICIENCY AND HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT ALL
YEAR WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH THINNER
JACKSON OF THIS EXCITING
MEASURE. WOULD LIKE ME TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR. LAST CALL
FOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
HEARING SEEN NINE MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
UTILIZING OUR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. HEARING SEE NO OBJECTION
EYES THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WE NOW
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO JUMP
BACK IN OUR FILE. GIVE US A
MOMENT UP HERE AT THE DESK TO
BE ABLE TO RECONFIGURE BILLS.
WE'RE GONNA START WITH FILE
ITEM SEVENTY TWO CENTER TAUGHT
ARE YOU PREPARED TO PRESENT SHE
IS MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
FIFTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA AND ACKLEY NEWBIES.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR TO FLOOR
SOURCE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB FOR FIFTY WHICH IS A
FOLLOW UP TO LAST YEAR'S
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FOUR SIX
EIGHT. LAST YEAR A. B. TWO FOUR
SIX EIGHT CHANGE THE
NOTIFICATION REQUIREMENT FOR A
BREEZE MOVING FROM ONE COUNTY
TO ANOTHER COUNTY. FROM FIVE
DAYS TO SEVENTY TWO HOURS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE LEGISLATION
DID NOT SPECIFY THE SAME CHANGE
FROM A PRE RELOCATED WITHIN THE
SAME COUNTY. A BEFORE FIFTY
ADDRESSES THAT COMMISSION AND
REQUIRES THE SAME NOTIFICATION
FOR RELOCATION WITHIN THE SAME
COUNTY. AB FOR FIFTY HAS
RECEIVED STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE BOOK TODAY. DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM ANY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SEEING AND
HEARING NONE IS TURNING
OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NON ICE THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO. SHE'S ME ICE THIRTY EIGHT
A NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY
NINE FILE ITEM EIGHTY NINE.
CENTER GALGIANI MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE FORTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA AND ACT
REALLY INTO TIRES SENATOR
GALGIANI THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS AB NINE FORTY NINE WILL
PROHIBIT THE INSTALLATION OF
UNSAFE TIRES ON CARS WHILE
MAINTAINING THE ABILITY OF
RETAILERS TO SELL THEM FOR
OTHER USES CONSUMERS PURCHASING
USED TIRES FOR USE ON THE ROAD
ARE OFTEN NOT AWARE OF THE TRUE
CONDITION ESPECIALLY IF THERE
IS NO VISIBLE DAMAGE LIES
AUTUMN APPEAR AUTOMOTIVE MOTIVE
REPAIRED IT IS ARE MORE IT
KATIE THAN CONSUMERS AND ARE IN
A BETTER POSITION TO JUDGE THE
SAFETY OF USED TIRES FRIENDS. A
LATE. AB NINE FORTY NINE IS AN
IMPORTANT. SIMILAR VERSION
SEVEN PASSING COLORADO OHIO AND
NEW JERSEY THE BILL'S RECEIVE
UNANIMOUS ROOF SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE ARRIVAL.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THE
SIDE OF. SITTING IN HEARING
NONE IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING NONE ICE THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ALONG TO FILE
ITEM NINETY TWO FILE ITEM
NINETY TWO SENATOR BELL MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE SIXTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER AN
ACT RELATING TO CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES. SENATOR BELL MATTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS BILL
DELETES THE REQUIREMENT FOR
NARCOTIC OFFENDERS TO REGISTER
WITH LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT NOW
UNDER THE CURRENT LAW A PERSON
CONVICTIONS OF CONVICTED OF
CERTAIN DRUG OFFENSES REQUIRED
REGISTER THEIR LOCAL POLICE
CHIEF OR SHERIFF AND EACH TIME
THE PERSON MOVES THEIR REQUIRED
TO RE REGISTER WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THAT AREA GOING
THROUGH THE SAME LABOR IS
PHOTOGRAPHING FINGERPRINTING
INFORMATION GET OUT GALLERY.
NOW. THIS LAW. IS OBSOLETE
BECAUSE ALL THIS INFORMATION IS
CURRENTLY HELD IN THEIR
CRIMINAL RECORD AND THAT RECORD
IS ELECTRONICALLY AVAILABLE
TRANSMITTED AND THE BILL WILL
SAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT COURT AND
INVALUABLE TIME AND RESOURCES
BY ELIMINATING THE REDUNDANCY
THAT EXIST BECAUSE OF MODERN
ELECTRONIC TRANSMISSION OF THE
CROWN. CV NOW TO SUPPORT
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS ARJUNA
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR BELL
DEBATER DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM
SEEING AND HEARING NONE IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING AND HEARING NON
ICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NINETY FOUR. SENATOR
HILL FILE ITEM NINETY FOUR.
PASS ON FILE FILE ITEM NINETY
SIX CENTER SKINNER. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS AN ACT
RELATING TO JUVENILES. SENATOR
SKINNER. I'M THANK YOU ARE
MADAM PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE DEALS
WITH JUVENILE TRANSFER TO ADULT
COURT UNDER OUR CURRENT STATUTE
WANTS TO TREAT JUVENILES
TRANSFERRED TO THE ADULT COURT
THEY MAY NOT BE REFERRED BACK
TO THE JUVENILE SYSTEM IT'S
SOMETHING WHAT THAT'S IN
STATUTE SO EVEN IF THE JUDGE.
DESIRES TO. PUT THE PROSECUTOR
JUDGE TO REFER TO THE JUVENILE
BACK TO JUVENILE COURT JUVENILE
SYSTEM THEY UNDER OUR STATUTE
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO SO AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE IS A
NARROWLY TAILORED REMEDY THAT
ALLOWS IN LIMITED SITUATIONS IT
ENSURES FAIRNESS AND ALLOWS YOU
TO RECEIVE RESOURCES AND
SERVICES IN THE JUVENILE SYSTEM
AMENDMENTS TAKE IN THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE REMOVED ALL
OPPOSITION. AND WITH THAT I
FEAR. DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM DEBATE OR DISCUSS.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS
BATES I. BELL I PURCHASED HI
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CHIANG I
DALY I DODD ARE THERE ALSO I
GALGIANI I GLAZER I GONZALEZ HI
GROWTH. HERTZBERG I HILL AYE
HUESO. I HER TITLE. I JACKSON
HI I JONES. BY LEYVA MCGUIRE BY
MITCHELL. BY MORNING BY MORE
LOCK. I'M A REAL. NIELSEN AYE
PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE I AM BURKE OUR CASKEY I
WINNER HI WILK HI. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS GROVE
LEYVA MORRELL. OUR EYES THIRTY
SIX NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE OLD
FOR SENATOR HERTZBERG MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL ELEVEN HUNDRED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KAMLAGER-DOVE OF AN ACT
REALLY INTO ELECTRIC VEHICLES
SENATOR HERTZBERG THANK OU
MADAM PRESIDENT THIS MEASURE
MAKES PARKING SPACES SERVED BY
ELECTRICAL VEHICLE CHARGING
EQUIPMENT COUNT AS A STANDARD
PARKING SPACE FOR PURPOSES OF
COMPLYING WITH IN THE APPLE
MINIMAL PARKING REQUIREMENTS
ESTABLISHED BY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THE REASON OF
COURSE. IS BECAUSE THE STATE
HAS A GOAL TO WILL DEPLOY A
QUARTER OF A MILLION PUBLIC
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
STATIONS TO SUPPORT OUR ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION ZERO
VEHICLES BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
UPDATE WE'VE OPENLY AND STOP AT
TWENTY THOUSAND SUCH BE
CHARGING STATIONS FALSE ART.
SCHOOL THAT'S PURPOSE MEASURE
RIVAL. THANK YOU CENTER
HERTZBERG DEBATER DISCUSSIONS
OR ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA. ATKINS I BATES NO
BELL I PORGES HI. BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CHIANG I DALY. I
DODD HI THERE ALSO I GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ HI
GROWTH. HERTZBERG I HILL AYE
HUESO. BY TITLE I JACKSON HI I
JONES NO LEYVA MCGUIRE HI
MITCHELL. HI MONNING I'M MORE
LUCK MORRELL NO NIELSEN. PAN I
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN I STONE.
HI NUMBER I LIKE KELSEY I
WINNER. HI WILK HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ARCHULETA HI.
GROWTH LEYVA MORE LUCK HI
NIELSEN. OUR EYES THIRTY FOUR
KNOWS THREE THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ALONG TO FILE ITEM ONE
TEN SENATOR MCGUIRE DO YOU WISH
TO TAKE THIS UP. TEMPORARILY
PASS ON FILE FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY SIX IS OUR NEXT ITEM.
MOVING ON TO ONE TWENTY SIX BY.
SENATOR REQUIRED YOU WISH TO
PASS TEMPORARILY ON THAT AS
WELL. ALL RIGHT. AND WE WILL
MOVE THEM TO FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY EIGHT. I'M SORRY ONE
THIRTY EIGHT HAS BEEN COMPLETED
WILL MOVE ON NOW TO FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY FIVE. ONE FORTY FIVE
CENTER HUESO YOU PREPARE TO
TAKE UP THE SIDE OF. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ A SOME OF
THE ELEVEN FIFTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GLORIA AND ACT REALLY
INTO COMMUNITY COLLEGES. WASTE
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE TO PRESENT AB ELEVEN FIFTY
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA THIS BILL OFFERS A
SIMPLE REQUIREMENT. FOR
CANDIDATES FOR ELECTION. OF
GOVERNING BOARDS OF SEND YOU
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS AND
GROW SMOKE. COULD YOU MARK A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT TO
FILE NOMINATING PAPERS IN MOST
LARGE CITIES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FOR MEMBERS ARE REQUIRED TO
EITHER PAY A FILING FEE OR
PRODUCE SIGNATURES FROM THE
COMMUNITY THAT THEY SEEK TO
PRESERVE REPRESENT. FOR THIS
TWENTY ONE OF GROSSMONT
DISTRICTS THESE OF. SIMPLE
REQUIREMENTS DO NOT EXIST. IT
THERE IS THERE COULD BE HARM
AND NOT REQUIRING OF CANDIDATES
ESPECIALLY FOR SMALLER
DISTRICTS SMALLER DISTRICTS.
NOT TO SEEK ANY KIND OF
COMMUNITY INVOLVEMENT OR AT A
CONTACT WITH INDIVIDUALS IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT WAS AN INSTANCE
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND FOR WHERE
OF A GENTLEMAN PUT HIS NAME ON
THE BALLOT WITHOUT. RICK OF
PHILLY NOT ANY SIGNATURES OR
MAKING ANY CONTACT WITH THE
COMMUNITY. HE HE RAN FOR SCHOOL
BOARD. BEAT THE CANDIDATE THAT
HE WAS LISTED AS A SCHOOL
TEACHER HE BEAT THE CANADA WAS
ENDORSED BY ALMOST EVERY
COMMUNITY GROUP. THIS A
GENTLEMAN ENDED UP HAVING
MENTAL ILLNESS PROBLEMS AND
THAT NEEDS TO BE ARE PREVENTED
SOMEHOW THAT GOT THROUGH THAT
INSTANCE IT WAS A CASE IN
ORANGE COUNTY. IN A IN A SMALL
A SCHOOL BOARD THERE. BUT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR ANY
CANDIDATE TO HAVE A SIGNATURE
COLLECTING REQUIREMENT I THINK
THIS BILL WOULD IT WAS CLOSE
THAT LOOP IN THIS. IN TO ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
CENTER WAY SHOWS HER ANY DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
BY BATES BELL I PURCHASED. HI.
BRADFORD I CARRY IT ALL. HI
JANE I DALY DODD HI THERE ALSO
I GALGIANI I GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ HI GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO. BY
OUR TOTAL. HI JACKSON HI I
JONES. LEYVA MCGUIRE BY
MITCHELL. BY MORNING I'M MORE
LUCK MORRELL NO NO SAN. PAN I
PORTANTINO I ROTH AYE RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN BY STONE.
NOVEMBER BY WHAT CASKEY I
WINNER BY WILK HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS BATES. DALY
NO. JONES NO LEYVA MORE LARK.
NO NIELSEN. ICE THIRTY ONE
KNOWS SIX THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ALONG NOW TO FILE ITEM
ONE FIFTY FOUR SENATOR STERN
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN OH SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH AND ACTING THE
CIVIL RIGHTS SENATOR STERN. I
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE PRESENT AB SIXTEEN OH
SEVEN. BOB THIS MEASURE MAY NOT
BE CONTROVERSIAL OR FACE ANY
OPPOSITION IT BEARS NOTING ON
WOMEN'S EQUALITY DAY. ITS
RELEVANCE. TO OUR HISTORY AND
PROMISES STILL NOT YET MET OF
EQUALITY IN THIS STATE. BACK IN
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE THAN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACQUI SPEAR
PAST AB ELEVEN HUNDRED WHICH
PROHIBITED BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA FROM CHARGING
DIFFERENT PRICES FOR SERVICES
OF SIMILAR LIKE KIND BASED ON
THE CUSTOMER'S GENDER UNLESS
THE PRICE DIFFERENTIAL COULD BE
JUSTIFIED. UPON THE AMOUNT OF
TIME DIFFICULTY OF COST OF
PROVIDING A SERVICE TO THINK
ABOUT IT HERE CUTTER A
LAUNDERER. OR EVEN AN AUTO
MECHANIC. IT IS ILLEGAL UNDER
CALIFORNIA STATE LAW THANKS TO
THAT THE PASSAGE OF THAT ACT TO
BE TO OFFER SIMILAR LIKE KIND
SERVICE AT A DIFFERENT PRICE
JUST BECAUSE YOU'RE A WOMAN OR
MAN. THE IN FOR LAW THOUGH IS
LEFT MANY GAPS AND LET MEANT
MANY BUSINESSES WITH
UNCERTAINTY IN LITIGATION RISK
BUT ALSO TO CUSTOMERS TO KNOW
THEIR RIGHTS AND PRIVILEGES
UNDER THIS IMPORTANT LAW TO AB
SIXTEEN OH SEVEN REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT CONSUMER AFFAIRS TO
PREPARE. A NOTICE IN
INFORMATION FOR IT MATERIALS IN
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES ENGLISH
SPANISH CHINESE TAGALOG
VIETNAMESE AND KOREAN AND THE
RIVER PROVIDE THEM AS NECESSARY.
AND A COPY OF THIS NOTICE WOULD
BE POSTED FOR ALL LOCAL
AGENCIES TO DOWNLOAD AND FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES MANY OF WHOM
ARE SMALL SMALL BUSINESSES TO
POST THIS AND UNDERSTAND THEIR
REQUIREMENTS UNDER THE LAW.
THAT THEY CAN AVOID UNNECESSARY
LITIGATION SO THEIR CUSTOMERS
CAN GET ONE STEP CLOSER TO A
QUALITY THERE'S STILL
UNFINISHED BUSINESS YET TO DO
PRICING IS STILL DISCRIMINATORY
IN MANY CIRCUMSTANCES. TODAY
BECKLEY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE ON
THIS BIPARTISAN MEASURE. THANK
YOU SENATOR STERN DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION. SEEING AND
HEARING NON WE ARE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE ROLE ONE TIME AND
PLACE THE ITEM ON CALL. MISTER
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. BILL BY BURGESS I
BRADFORD I CAMBIADO I CHIANG I
DALY HI DODD HI THERE ALSO I
GALGIANI. I GLAZER HI GONZALEZ
I GROWTH. HERTZBERG AYE HILL
AYE HUESO. I TITLE. JACKSON HI
FI JONES. HI LEYVA MCGUIRE OKAY.
MITCHELL BY MORNING I'M MORE
LUCK I'M A REAL I NIELSEN. PAN
HI PORTANTINO. FIVE ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE I AM BURKE. HI WHAT
COUNTY I WIENER AYE WILK OKAY.
IS SINCE THE SENATE REQUIRE
STILL HERE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BATES HI GROWTH.
FOR TITLE BY GROW BY LEYVA
MCGUIRE. HI NIELSEN. VICE
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY ONE FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTY ONE SENATOR
CAFIERO ARE YOU PREPARED TO
TAKE THE SIDE OF. FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTY ONE AB SIX FIFTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EGGMAN. ALREADY
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX FIFTY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN AN
ACT REALLY INTO AGRICULTURE AND
MAKING A PREPARATION THEREFORE.
SENATOR CAFIERO FLOORS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT AB SIX
FIFTY SEVEN ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN A
MEASURE THAT WOULD EXTEND THE
SUNSET DATE. FOR COMMERCIAL
FEED CENSURE AND INSPECTION
TONNAGE TAX FROM JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. THE BILL
ALSO INCREASES THE MAXIMUM RATE
OF THE TENANTS TAX FROM FIFTEEN
CENTS TO TWENTY FIVE CENTS PER
TON OF COMMERCIAL FEED SOLD THE
FUNDING IS USED FOR EDUCATION
AND RESEARCH REGARDING THE SAFE
HANDLING OF COMMERCIAL FEED.
THESE LICENSE AND INSPECTION
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN IN THE
DISTANCE SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE AND ENSURE A SAFE FEED
SUPPLY FOR THE LIVE STOCK AND
THE TREE IN OUR STATE. AN
INDUSTRY ADVISORY BOARD THAT
ASSISTED IN THE FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE IN MANAGING THE
PROGRAM AND THE BOARD PROVIDES
OVERSIGHT TO. OUR ADDRESS THE
BILL IS INDUSTRY SPONSORED AND
HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IBM.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SEEING AND HEARING NONE. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES HI BILL. HI BURGESS I
BRADFORD I CAMBIADO. BY CHIANG.
DELHI I DODD. HI THERE ALSO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ BY GROWTH. HERTZBERG.
BY HILL AYE HUESO AYE OR TITLE
I JACKSON I JONES BY LEYVA
MCGUIRE. MITCHELL BY MORNING BY
MORE LUCK I'M A REAL. NIELSEN
AYE PAN I PORTANTINO HI ROTH HI
RUBIO I SKINNER. BY STERN I
STONE. NUMBER. IA CATHY BYE
WINNER BY WILK HI. SENATOR
KIRBY GYRO MOVES A CALL MOVING
ON NOW TO FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
THREE SENATOR BELL MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
ANAK LINDA GREENHOUSE GASES
SENATOR BELL. MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE INVESTMENT
PROGRAMS WHICH ARE FUNDED BY
THE CAP AND TRADE DOLLARS TO
POST INFORMATION ONLINE ABOUT
APPLICATION DEADLINES
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND AGENCY CONTACTS
IT WILL INCREASE TRANSPARENCY.
IMPROVE ACCESS TO THESE
PROGRAMS FOR COMMITTEE FOR
COMMUNITY STATEWIDE PUBLIC
INFORMATION IS ALWAYS GOOD HAS
NO NO VOTES URGE I VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR BILL DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION. ON FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTY THREE MR SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE BELL. BY BURGESS AYE
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO I CHIANG
I DALY I DOT HI THERE ALSO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. I HERTZBERG.
HI HILL AYE HUESO I TITLE I
JACKSON HI I JONES. LEYVA
MCGUIRE. MITCHELL HI MONNING.
I'M MORE LUCK I'M REAL. BY
NIELSEN BY PAN BY PORTANTINO I
ROTH I RUBIO AYE SKINNER. I
STERN I STONE BY AMBERG. I
WOULD COUNTY I WINNER BY WILK
HI SENATOR BILL MOVES TO CALL
MOVING ON NOW TO FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY WIENER. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE FIFTY SEVEN BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AND
ECHOING HOUSING AND CLAIM
THERE'S THREATS TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY THANK YOU SENATOR
WINNER I THANK YOU AND
PRESIDENT WE HAVE A BLOCKBUSTER
HERE COLLEAGUES SIDE EIGHTY
NINE FIFTY SEVEN IS THIS YEAR'S
HOUSING ON THE BUT STILL MAKES
TECHNICAL NON SUBSTANTIVE
CHANGE THANK YOU ALL THE
PROPOSALS HAVE BEEN THOROUGHLY
VETTED WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
CONFIRM. THAT THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN IDOL. BAY DOOR
DISCUSSION. ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES AYE BILL. BY BURGESS
I BRADFORD I KELLY AT ALL I
CHIANG. I DALY AYE DODD HI
THERE ALSO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH. I
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO. I
OUR TITLE. I JACKSON HI I JONES
I LEYVA. MCGUIRE MITCHELL HI
MONNING. I'M MORE LUCK I'M A
REAL. AYE NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO I ROTH BY RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN AYE STONE. I
AMBERG ABA CASKEY I WINNER HI
WILK HI SENATOR WIENER MOVES A
CALL MOVING NOW TO FILE ITEM
ONE SEVENTY SIX SENATOR RUBIO
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR NINETY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO
INEQUITY COMMUNICATIONS. SENATE
EIGHTY FOUR NINETY SEVEN WHICH
EXTENDS THE P. UC'S AUTHORITY
TO COLLECT A SURCHARGE TO FUND
THE DEAF AND DISABLED HAD
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROGRAM THIS
PROGRAM PROVIDES CRITICAL
TELEPHONE EQUIPMENT AND
SERVICES TO HELP DEAF AND
DISABLED PEOPLE COMMUNICATE
WITH FAMILY FRIENDS OR
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS THIS
BILL HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO ATTORNEY DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THE SIDE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS.
HI BATES HI BILL I BRIDGES HI
BRADFORD I CAMBIADO I CHIANG. I
DALY AYE DODD BY THERE ALSO I
GALGIANI I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROW. I HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO. BY OUR TITLE I JACKSON
HI BY JONES. I LEYVA. MCGUIRE.
MITCHELL BYE BYE MONNING I'M
MORE LOCK BY MERRELL. NIELSEN
HI PAN BY PORTANTINO AYE ROTH.
BY RUBIO AYE SKINNER I STERN I
STONE. BY HAMBURG I WOULD
COUNTY AYE WIENER AYE WILK I.
SENATOR RUBIO MOVES A CALL NEXT
UP IS FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN WE WILL PASS TEMPORARILY
ON THAT ITEM AND MOVED TO FILE
ITEM ONE EIGHTY SENATOR GLAZER
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
YOUR BY FIVE. ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER POWER QUE HAN
AND ACT REALLY INTO PUBLIC
CONTRACTS SENATOR RELATIONS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
A ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REBEKAH POWER
QUE HAN THE BILL WOULD ALLOW
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES TO UTILIZE. THE
CONSTRUCTION MANAGER GENERAL
CONTRACTOR HE KERMAN PROCESS.
FOR CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS THAT
ARE NOT PART OF THE STATE
HIGHWAY SYSTEM. THIS DELIVERY
METHOD ALLOWS THE GENERAL
CONTRACTOR TO ENGAGE THE
CONSTRUCTION MANAGER EARLY ON.
TO PROVIDE INPUT DURING THE
DESIGN PROCESS. THIS WOULD HELP
THEM TO WORK COLLABORATIVELY TO
DEVELOP THE PROJECT SCOPE.
OPTIMIZED DESIGN IMPROVE
QUALITY AND MANAGE COSTS.
CALTRANS CITED A FORTY FOUR
PLUS MILLION DOLLAR COST
AVOIDANCE SAVINGS BY USING THE
BILL'S PROPOSED DELIVERY
PROCESS IN THEIR TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN EFFICIENCY
REPORT. NOW EXISTING LAW DOES
NOT ALLOW REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES TO
UTILIZE THIS MODEL AND I HAS
REQUIRED A PATCHWORK OF BILLS
BY THE LEGISLATURE TO ALLOW THE
USE OF THIS METHOD THIS BILL
WOULD PROVIDE REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES.
ANOTHER TOOL TO DELIVER
PROJECTS MORE EFFICIENTLY AND
PROVIDE OPTIONS FOR SMALLER
MUNICIPALITIES TO UTILIZE THIS
PROCUREMENT PROCESS FOR OFF
HIGHWAY PROJECTS. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER GLAZER DEBATER
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM IS ARE
ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SING
IN HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. I ARE TO THAT A AYE
ATKINS. AYE BATES AYE BILL I
PURCHASED I BRADFORD I CAN BE
AT ALL I CHIANG AYE DALY AYE
DODD. ARE THERE ALSO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROVE I HERTZBERG I
HILL AYE HUESO I TITLE I
JACKSON HI I JONES. I LEYVA.
MCGUIRE MITCHELL HI MONNING.
I'M MORE LUCK I AM A REAL. I
NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH HI RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN. AYE STONE AYE AMBERG I
WOULD COUNTY AYE WIENER AYE
WILK HI SENATOR GLAZER MOVES A
CALL MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY ONE SENATOR KIRBY IT'LL-
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR TWELVE BY
SOME MEMBER QUIRK SILVA AND ACT
REALLY INTO ESCROW AGENTS
CENTER CABALLERO THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB FOR TWELVE ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHARON QUIRK
SILVA THE FINANCIALLY FINANCIAL
ACCOUNTING STANDARDS BOARD
RECENTLY ADOPTED GUIDELINES TO
REVISE LEASE ACCOUNTING
STANDARDS AND ONE OF THE
CHANGES TO THE ACCOUNTING
STANDARDS INVOLVES THE RE
CLASSIFICATION OF LEASES. FASB
PROPOSES TO CHANGE THE METHOD
OF ACCOUNTING FOR LEASES BY
REQUIRING THAT THEY BE
RECOGNIZED AS AN ASSET AS WELL
AS A LIABILITY THIS CHANGE WILL
AFFECT WHAT MAY BE INCLUDED AS
A CURRENT LIABILITY ON THE
BALANCE SHEET AND THEREFORE THE
CALCULATION OF LIQUIDITY
REQUIREMENTS FOR LICENSEES.
UNDER THE ESCROW LAW. THIS
OVERSIGHT ANTICIPATES THAT AND
WITH THIS CHANGE MOST LICENSEES
SPECIFICALLY INDEPENDENT ESCROW
COMPANIES WILL NO LONGER BE
ABLE TO COMPLY WITH THE
LIQUIDITY REQUIREMENT AND
THEREFORE NOT BE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN THEIR LICENSES OR
PERFORM ESCROW IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA'S INDEPENDENT ESCROW
LICENSEES CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
THEIR NECESSARY AND VALUABLE
SERVICES TO THE PUBLIC. THE
BILL WOULD EXEMPT THE
INDEPENDENT ESCROW LICENSEES
FROM A CHANGE IN ACCOUNTING
GUIDELINES THAT THAT WAS
ADOPTED BY THE FINANCIAL
ACCOUNTING STANDARDS BOARD
WITHOUT THIS EXCEPTION. THESE
CALIFORNIA COMPANIES WOULD
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN
THEIR LICENSES AND PROVIDE
ESCROW SERVICES THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION NO THE VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK CENTER CUBBY BUT
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THE
SITE. THE BAIT OR DISCUSSION
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES I BILL BY PORGES I
BRADFORD I CAN BE AT ALL I
CHIANG. I DALY I DODD. I THE
RUSSELL AYE GALGIANI I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ HI GROW. HERTZBERG I
HILL AYE HUESO. BY TITLE. I
JACKSON HI HI JONES. HI LEYVA
REQUIRE MITCHELL. HI MONNING.
I'M MORE LUCK I'M A REAL. BY
NELSON. I PAN AYE PORTANTINO BY
ROTH I RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN
AYE STONE. I AMBERG I HAVE A
COUNTY I WINNER BY WILK. HI.
SENATOR CAFIERO MOVES A CALL
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY TWO SENATOR RUBIO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE TWENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA AN ACT
RELATING TO PROTECTIVE ORDERS.
SENATOR RUBIO THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT AB NINE TWENTY FIVE
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT
SENSITIVE INFORMATION ABOUT A
MINOR IN A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDER AND CIVIL
HARASSMENT RESTRAINING ORDER IS
KEPT CONFIDENTIAL. RECENT
AMENDMENTS EXTEND COMPONENTS OF
THIS BILL TO THE CODE OF CIVIL
PROCEDURE SPECIFICALLY TO THOSE
WHO HAVE FILED A CIVIL
HARASSMENT. RESTRAINING ORDER
THIS INCLUDES CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS MEDICAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS AND
PROFESSIONALS AND
NONPROFESSIONAL SUPERVISORS FOR
VISITATIONS BY ALLOWING THE
COURTS THE AUTHORITY TO
DISCLOSE INFORMATION TO
INDIVIDUALS NECESSARY TO
ENFORCING THESE PROTECTIVE
ORDERS EIGHTY NINE TWENTY FIVE
WILL ENSURE THAT SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
HARASSMENT HAVE THE PROPER
PROTECTIONS. PLACE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
APPLE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO DEBATER
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM BATES
OR DISCUSSION SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE BILL I BRIDGES I BRADFORD I
CAMBIADO. CHIANG BY CARRIER I
DALY I DODD I'D ALSO I GALGIANI
I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROWTH. I
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO BY
OUR TITLE BY JACKSON HI I JONES.
BY LEYVA MCGUIRE MITCHELL. BY
MORNING I'M MORE LUCK I'M RALPH
BY NELSON I PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER
AYE STERN AYE STONE AYE OBERG.
IOWA CASKEY. BY WIENER AYE WILK
HI. SENATOR RUBIO MOVES TO A
CALL. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY THREE SENATOR WILK
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE ROOM
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE THIRTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PATTERSON AN ACT RELATING TO
STANDARDIZED TESTS SENATOR WILK
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMAN PATTERSON AND RICE
PRESENT A. B. ONE TWO THREE
FOUR WHICH SEEKS TO AMEND
OUTDATED LAWS GOVERNING
STANDARDIZED TESTING IN
CALIFORNIA SO THAT AMERICAN
COLLEGE TESTING ALSO KNOWN AS A
C. T. THEY OFFER A SEVEN TESTS
TO STUDENTS IN JULY. IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NEARLY FIFTY
HUNDRED STUDENTS OUTSIDE A
CALIFORNIA SO THEY COULD TAKE
THE A. C. T. IN JULY ALL OTHER
STATES HAVE CALIFORNIA AND NEW
YORK OFFERED JULY TEST STATE.
THE CURRENT TELL A TEST
DEVELOPMENT CYCLE TO PRODUCE
REQUIRED TESTS FORMS WILL TAKE
THE A. C. T. AS LONG AS TWO AND
A HALF YEARS HOWEVER IF THIS
BILL BECOMES LAW THEY COULD
START OFFERING THE ADDITIONAL
SUMMER TESTED STUDENTS NEXT
YEAR. AB ONE TWO THREE FOUR HAS
NO OPPOSITION AND HAS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR WILL
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. OUT WHICH LETTER. CAN
I BATES I BILL. I BRIDGES I
BRADFORD I CAN BE AT ALL BY
CHIANG AYE DALY AYE DODD. HI
THERE ALSO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH. I
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO AYE
OR TITLE I JACKSON HI I JONES.
BY LEYVA MCGUIRE MITCHELL BY
MORNING I'M MORE LOCK I AM A
REAL AYE NIELSEN. AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER. I STERN AYE STONE.
I AM BURKE BOB CASKEY I WINNER
BY WILK I. SENATOR WORLD MOVES
A CALL MOVING ON FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY FOUR HAS BEEN DISPENSED
WITH FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
SENATOR HERTZBERG MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN TWENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW AND ACT
REALLY CANNABIS AND CLEARING
THEIR THROATS TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU UP MADAM PRESIDENT IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE
VOTERS. OF CALIFORNIA BY A 57%
MARGIN PASSED PROPOSITION SIXTY
FOUR WHICH LEGALIZED THE ADULT
USE OF CANNABIS IN CALIFORNIA.
A ONE OF THE REGULATORY
STANDARDS ESTABLISHED BECAUSE
OF THE LEGALIZATION IS THE
REQUIREMENT THAT MANUFACTURES
PLACE A UNIVERSAL SYMBOL ON ALL
CANNABIS PRODUCTS THIS MEASURE
CHANGE THE LAW TO REDUCE THE
SIZE OF THE CYMBAL BECAUSE
THERE'S CERTAIN CANNABIS
PRIVATE PRODUCTS THAT DON'T
TAKE THAT BIGGER LABEL. IT
WOULD PASSED THE ASSEMBLY BY
SEVENTY THREE TO ZERO I ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES AYE BILL I PURCHASED. BY
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CHIANG I
DALY I DODD. HI THERE ALSO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO HI FOR TITLE.
HI JACKSON HI I JONES I LEYVA
MCGUIRE MITCHELL. BY MORNING
I'M MORE LUCK I'M A REAL.
NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH I RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN I STONE I HAMBURG. OUR
COUNTY I WINNER. BY WILK HI
SENATE. SENATOR HERTZBERG MOVES
TO CALL WE WILL BE GOING
THROUGH THIS ONE MORE TIME WHEN.
THE GOOD SENATOR FROM THE NORTH
COAST RETURNS WE ARE NOW MOVING
TO FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY NINE BY
SENATOR. ALLEN ONE EIGHTY NINE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO SIXTY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO ENACT
REALLY INTO PLYMOUTH SENATOR
ALLEN MADAM PRESIDENT THIS BILL
EXTENDS EXISTING HEALTH
PROTECTIONS FOR INFANTS WORKING
IN TV AND MOVIES TO THOSE
WORKING ALL ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRIES INCLUDING STREAMING
SERVICES AND SOCIAL MEDIA IT
HAS NO OPPOSITION THE BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
BOTH THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE.
THERE'S A FRESHMAN. THANK YOU
SENATOR ALLEN ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
HI BILL I BRIDGES I BRADFORD I
COMING HERO I CHIANG. I DALY I
DODD BY THE RAZA I GALGIANI I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROW. I
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO I
TITLE I JACKSON HI I JONES I
LEYVA. REQUIRE MITCHELL. HI
MONNING BY MORE LUCK. I'M A
REAL. I NIELSEN I PAN BY
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER. I STERN AYE STONE
AYE AMBERG I WOULD COUNTY I
WINNER BY WILK HI SENATOR ALLEN
MOVES TO CALL MOVING ON NOW TO
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY. BY
SENATOR DOLLY ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN THIRTY THREE BY
THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY AND
ACCORDING TO TRIBAL GAMING AND
CLEARING THEIR THROATS TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY SENATOR
DOLLINGER THEY RAN A PRESIDENCY
HOW WE CAN DO FOR THAT GUY THIS
TIME. AB THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE
RATIFIED THE AMENDMENT TO THE
TRIBAL STATE GAMING COMPACT
INTER TO BETWEEN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE SUSANVILLE
IN RANCHERIA. AND WOULD ALLOW
THE TRY TO CONTINUE TO OPERATE
SMALL TWO HUNDRED TWENTY SLOT
MACHINE GAMING FACILITY UNDER A
NEW TRAVEL COMPACT FOR
ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
THE FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES
LOCATED IN LASSEN COUNTY AND
CONSIST OF MORE THAN TWELVE
HUNDRED MEMBERS THE TRIBE
CURRENTLY OPERATES. IT'S GAMING
FACILITY UNDER THE NINETEEN
NINETY NINE. TRIBAL STATE
GAMING COMPACT WHICHIS SET TO
EXPIRE IN TWENTY TWENTY. THE
TRIBES DIAMOND MOUNTAIN CASINO
HOTEL BREWERY PROVIDES
EMPLOYMENT FOR A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY NINE PEOPLE I DON'T SIX
OF WHOM ARE OF TRIBAL MEMBERS.
THE TRIBES A DIME MAGAZINE
OVERSEAS WE GAMING REVENUES ARE
A VITAL FUNDING SOURCE FOR THE
TRIBES GOVERNMENT AND SUPPORT
PROGRAMS SUCH AS EDUCATION
CHILD CARE ELDER SERVICES FOR
THE TRIBES MEMBERS THIS NEW
COMPACT AUTHORIZED. I DO
OPERATE EXTREME OF TWELVE
HUNDRED SLOTS MACHINES AT NO
MORE THAN TWO GAMING FACILITIES
LOCATED ON ELIGIBLE IT INDIAN
LANDS HELD IN TRUST FOR THE
TRIBES AND LOCATED WITHIN THE
BOUNDARIES OF THE TRIBE'S
RESERVATION. THE TRIBE HAS
AGREED TO PAY THE STATE'S PRO
RADISH OF COST THE STATE IS
INCURRED FOR THESE PERFORMANCES
OF DUTIES UNDER THE COMPACT.
CERTAIN TERMS OF THE COMPACT
RELATED TO THE LICENSE
REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT
ENVIRONMENTAL MITIGATION
PATRONS PROTECTION LABOR AND
PUBLIC HEALTH PROVISIONS ARE
SUBSTANTIAL. SUBSTANTIALLY THE
SAME AS RECENT COMPAQ'S THIS
COMIC HAS NO OPPOSITION AND IS
STRONGLY SUPPORTED BY THE
SUSANVILLE COMMUNITY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
LABOR I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK THANK YOU SIR
DAWALY ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON THIS ITEM. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
HI BILL HI PORGES I BRADFORD.
CABALLERO I CHIANG I DALY I
DODD HI THERE ALSO I GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ HI
GROWTH. I HERTZBERG AYE HILL I
WAS SO HI TITLE I JACKSON I
JONES. I LEYVA. REQUIRE
. I
STONE. I AM BURKE I WOULD
CASKEY BY WINNER. I WILK HI
SENATOR DOLLY MOVES A CALL
MOVING ON NOW TO FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY SIX FILE ITEM ONE NINETY
SIX. SENATOR HILL MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE TWELVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI AND HACK
REALLY INTO MARINE INVASIVE
SPECIES SENATOR HILL THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT THE IN MEMBERS
TODAY I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB NINE TWELVE WHICH WILL
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
BALLAST WATER DISCHARGE PROGRAM
IS NOT PREEMPTED. BY RECENTLY
ADOPTED FEDERAL LEGISLATION AND
PROTECT OUR CLOSE COASTAL
WATERS FROM THE THREAT OF
MARINE INVASIVE SPECIES IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX THE LEGISLATURE
ESTABLISHED ASPIRATIONAL
BALLAST WATER DISCHARGE
PERFORMANCE STANDARDS FOR LARGE
OCEAN GOING VESSELS ENTERING
STATE WATERS THE STANDARDS WERE
THE STRICTEST IN THE NATION AND
MEANT TO BE PHASED IN TO ALLOW
TIME FOR TECHNOLOGY TO DEVELOP.
THE GOAL WAS TO HAVE CALIFORNIA
LEADS THE NATION WITH THE MOST
PROTECTIVE BALLAST WATER
DISCHARGE SANDERS UNFORTUNATELY
ENSHRINING STRICT STANDARDS IN
STATUTE WAS NOT ENOUGH TO DRIVE
TECHNOLOGY TO A POINT WHERE
TREATMENT SYSTEMS COULD MEET
THOSE STANDARDS THE LATEST
REPORT APPROVED IN DECEMBER
TWENTY EIGHTEEN FOUND THAT THE
INTERIM PERFORMANCE STANDARDS
CANNOT BE MET DUE TO A LACK OF
CAPABLE TECHNOLOGY. AB NINE
TWELVE WILL PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
TIME FOR TECHNOLOGY TO ADVANCE
TO MEET OUR CURRENT STANDARD
WHILE CONTINUING TO PROTECT OUR
COASTAL WATERS FROM THE HARMFUL
IMPACT OF A MARINE INVASIVE
SPECIES AB T. NINE TWELVE IS
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LANDS COMMISSION AND HAD
NO OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR RIVAL COLLEGE DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM IS
ERNIE DEBATE DISCOVER BUT
SEEING AND HEARING NONE. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES AYE BILL I BRIDGES I
BRADFORD. I CAN BE ERA I CHIANG
I DALY AYE DODD. HI THERE ALSO
I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO AYE HER
TITLE. I JACKSON HI I JONES. I
LEYVA MCGUIRE MITCHELL I
MONNING BY MORE LUCK I AM A
REAL. BY NELSON. I PAN AYE
PORTANTINO I ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE. I
AMBERG OUR CASKEY I WINNER BY
WILK. SENATOR HILL MOVES TO
CALL MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY SEVEN SENATOR WIENER
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE TWENTY THREE
BY A SEVEN MEMBER WICKS AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTRICITY SENATOR
WIENER I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TRYING TO PRESIDENT I'M
PRESENTING AB NINE TWENTY THREE
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WORKS COLLEAGUES AB NINE TWENTY
THREE WILL ALLOW THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA RAPID
TRANSIT DISTRICT ALSO KNOWN AS
PART OF TO PURCHASE ELECTRICITY
DIRECTLY FROM THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATOR
CURRY SO. AS WELL AS FROM OTHER
GENERATORS AND POWER MARKETERS
BAR IS THE ONLY LOAD SERVING
AND CITY IN CALIFORNIA WHOSE
ENERGY PROCUREMENT OPTIONS OR
LIMITED BY STATUTE IN THE WAY
THAT THE LAW CURRENTLY PROVIDES
A. B. NINE TWENTY THREE WILL
ROUND OUT PARTS ABILITY TO
PARTICIPATEEFFICIENTLY IN CHI
SO WHOLESALE MARKETS AS A LOAD
SERVING ENTITY JUST LIKE EVERY
OTHER LOW SERVING ENTITY AND
ALLOW IT TO INTEGRATE ITS
RENEWABLES ENERGY SUPPLY
ECONOMICALLY AND POLITELY INTO
THE SYSTEM. THE AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED IN THE SENATE ENERGY
COMMITTEE WILL REQUIRE I ANNUAL
REPORTING A BARK DISSIPATION
THE WHOLESALE MARKET THIS
LEGISLATION WILL SAY BAR UP TO
ONE POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY AND THIRD PARTY
TRANSACTION COSTS AB NINE
TWENTY THREE HAS NO. OPPOSITION
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER WINNER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING AND HEARING ON
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. HI ARCHIE
LETTER I ATKINS AYE BATES AYE
BILL FIVE LARGEST AYE BRADFORD
I CAMBIADO I CHIANG I DALY AYE
DODD BY THEY'RE ALSO. I
GALGIANI I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROW AYE HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO HI TITLE. I JACKSON HI I
JONES I LEYVA. MCGUIRE MITCHELL
BY MORNING BY MORE LOCK I'M
REAL. I NIELSEN. I PAN AYE
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO AYE
SKINNER I STERN. AYE STONE AYE
AMBERG I WOULD COUNTY BY WINNER
HI WILK BY SENATOR WIENER MOVES
A CALL MOVING ON NOW TO FILE
ITEM ONE NINETY EIGHT SENATOR
MONNING. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
FORTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA AN ACT RELATING TO THE
COYOTE VALLEY CONSERVATION
PROGRAM SENATOR MINING THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS
EIGHTY NINE FORTY EIGHT
ESTABLISHES THE THIRTY VALLEY
CONTENT CONSERVATION PROGRAM
COVERING MORE THAN SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND ACRES TO IMPLEMENT
RESTORATION PRESERVATION AND
RECREATION PROJECTS NESTLED
BETWEEN THE FAST GROWING CITIES
OF SAN JOSE IN MORGAN HILL IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY THE CLEAR
THE VALLEY IS UNIQUE TREASURE
WITH ITS ACTIVE FARM LANDS
WETLANDS WILDLIFE HABITATS AND
FLOOD PLAINS. THE NEED TO
PROTECT THE QUERY VALLEY FROM
DEVELOPMENT PRESSURES GAINING
MORE RECOGNITION BY THE STATE
BUT NO PROGRAM EXISTS THAT
FOCUSES LOCAL AND STATE EFFORTS
TO PRESERVE AND RESTORE EQUITY
VALLEY EIGHTY NINE FORTY EIGHT
SIX TO ENSURE THE CODY VALLEY
IS PROTECTED FOR OPEN SPACE
WILDLIFE WATER RECREATIONAL ON
AGRICULTURAL PURPOSES MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE THERE'S BEEN NO OPPOSITION.
IN NO VOTES CAST ON THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU. Q. SENATOR
MORNING ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SENATOR CAFIERO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
QUESTION WOULD YOU ACCEPT THE
QUESTION ON BEHALF OF THE
AUTHOR CENTER MONEY E. S.
BLANKET ACTION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MY QUESTION HAS TO DO AND
IN THE MEAT GIVEN THE CONTEXT
IS. SAN JOSE HAS A DENT HAD
IDEA HAS IDENTIFIED FOR THE
TWENTY YEARS KARAOKE VALLEY IS
THE AREA THAT THEY WOULD EXPAND
INTO AND- THEY HAVE A PLAN FOR
CONCERTS. CAN CONSIDERABLE UP
HOUSING AND HI TECH DEVELOPMENT
THERE THE CITY OF SALINAS
THROUGH THEM ON THEIR PROJECT
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T DO A SEQUIN
ALICE'S. TO DETERMINE WHAT THE
IMPACT IS GOING TO BE ON THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES WE
ENDED UP NEGOTIATING A DEAL THE
DOT COM INDUSTRY FELL AND SO
THEY NEVER ENDED UP BUILDING IT
SO MY QUESTION IS IF YOU KNOW
WHETHER THEY'RE REQUIRED TO DO
A SEQUEL ANALYSIS. OF ANY
CHANGES TO A PLAN IN THE CAIRO
KELLY IN THE IMPACT IT WILL
HAVE ON THE SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES AND PARTICULARLY
CONCERNED ABOUT SALINAS
HOLLISTER AND LOS BANOS WHICH
ARE ALL IN MY DISTRICT.
QUESTION I DO NOT KNOW THE
ANSWER I THINK IN ESTABLISHING
THE OPEN SPACE AUTHORITY THE
PURPOSE IS NOT TO HAVE
DEVELOPMENT THAT WOULD BE
SUBJECT TO SEA QUEST THERE'S
NOTHING IN THE FLOOR NOW SAYS
THAT SUGGESTS ANY WAIVER OF
SEAT OR ANY SUPER REQUIREMENTS
SO I'LL HAVE TO LOOK INTO THAT
FOR YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT OF MY OWN TIME.
LIKE FICTION I YOU KNOW WHAT I
ATE THE COYOTE VALLEY IS
EXACTLY AS YOU DESCRIBED IT IN
ITS VERY VERY SIMILAR TO SO THE
SALINAS VALLEY IN ITS THE
ABILITY BRO AND TO CREATE OPEN
SPACE IN FIREMAN BUT MY CONCERN
IS THAT THERE'S BEEN.
CONSIDERABLE GROWTH IN THE JOB.
IN JOBS CREATED IN THE SILICON
VALLEY. PUSHED THAT HAS CREATED
TREMENDOUS PRESSURE IN RURAL
AREAS THAT ARE TRYING TO
MAINTAIN THE RURAL CHARACTER
THAT HAVE A- LACK OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THAT HAVE VERY LOW
WAGES TO COMPETE WITH THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT LIVE IN IN THE
SILICON VALLEY. SOME A LITTLE
BIT NERVOUS ABOUT. CREATING A
CONSERVANCY WITHOUT THERE BEING
SOME ANALYSIS OF WHAT IT'S
GOING TO DO TO OUR OWN REGIONS
AS WE START TO LOSE
AGRICULTURAL LAND AROUND US SO
BECAUSE OF THAT I'M GONNA HAVE
TO VOTE NO ON THIS PARTICULAR A
PROPOSAL. BUT I DO UNDERSTAND
THE BEAUTY OF THE OF THE PEYOTE
VALLEY BUT I ALSO RECOGNIZE THE
BEAUTY OF MY DISTRICT AS WELL
AND I'M VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT THE IMPACTS ON THAT SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. IF YOU WERE TO.
THANK YOU SIR ANY FOR THEIR
DEBATER DISCUSSION. SEEING
HEARING ON SENATOR MORNING YOU
MAY CLOSE THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE IT AND JUSTIN MY
CLOTHES I WILL COMMENT THERE
HAS BEEN CERTAIN DEVELOPMENT
APPROVED INCLUDING EXPANSION OF
GAVILAN COLLEGE IN SOME OTHER
AGREED TO PROJECTS IN THE
REGION AGAIN THERE'S BEEN NO
OPPOSITION FROM LOCAL
AUTHORITIES LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION IN THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY I URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE. ALL DEBATE HAVE A WE ARE
NOW GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
ROLE TWICE AND CLOSE THE ROLE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I
ATKINS BY BATES. BILL I PORGES.
HI BRADFORD I COME A YELLOW NO
CHIANG I DALY I DODD I THE
RUSSELL HI GALGIANI I GLAZER I
CAN SALAS I GROWTH. HERTZBERG I
HILL AYE HUESO. BY TADO I
JACKSON HI I JONES BY LEYVA
MCGUIRE. HI MITCHELL HI MONEY
I'M MORE LOCK MORRELL NO
NIELSEN NO PAN BY PORTANTINO. I
ROTH BY RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN BY STONE BY. NUMBER OUR
CASKEY BY WINNER HI WILK HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BATES HI. GROVE LEYVA MORE LUCK
HI. I THIRTY FIVE KNOWS THREE
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON
NOW TO FILE ITEM FOR TWO
FIFTEEN SENATOR WILK. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN FOURTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PATTERSON AND
ACCOLADES TELECOMMUNICATIONS
AND CLING THEIR THREAT TO TAKE
PICKED ME THE SENATOR WELL
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS ARE RICE PERCENT A. B.
FIFTEEN FOURTEEN ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON AB
FIFTEEN FORTY WILL MAKE A
SIMPLE CHANGE TO THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES CODE INSURING THAT
THE CALIFORNIA PHONES PROGRAM
REMAINS ACCESSIBLE TO THOSE WHO
NEED IT MOST THIS PROGRAM
SERVES MORE FIVE THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE DEAF.
TABLE. TELEPHONES THAT MAY HAVE
LARGER TO MAKE IT EASIER.
VOLUMES TO MAKE IT EASIER TO
HEAR AND FLASHING LIGHTS TO
INDICATE INCOMING CALLS.
ADVOCATES TO THE PROGRAM S.
HAVE A HEALTHCARE PROVIDER
CERTIFIED THEIR NEED AND SIGN
OFF ON THEIR APPLICATION THE
CURRENT LIST OF ELIGIBLE
PROVIDERS EXCLUDES NURSE
PRACTITIONERS WHO OFTEN SERVICE
FRONTLINE PROVIDERS IN MANY
COMMUNITIES. WITH PHYSICIAN
SHORTAGES PARTICULARLY IN THE
RURAL PARTS OF THE STATE. AB
FIFTEEN FORTY WILL SOLVETHIS
PROBLEM BY ADDING NURSE
PRACTITIONERS TO THE LIST
CERTIFIED PROVIDERS THIS BILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION IS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. ANY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM. THE DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SEEING AND HEARING NONE. MISTER
SECRETARY. I'M SORRY IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION SUBSTITUTING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING AND HEARING NONE I
THIRTY NINE KNOWS HERE ON THE
URGENCY BUYS THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO ON THE MEASURE MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM TO SIXTEEN
SENATOR RALPH. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN FIFTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA AN ACT RELATING
TO HEALING ARTS. SENATOR ROBB
THING THEN PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
THIS BILL UPDATES THE BOARD OF
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES SUPERVISION
STATUTE TO ALLOW A LICENSED
EDUCATIONAL PSYCHOLOGIST TO ACT
AS A SUPERVISOR FOR ASSOCIATE
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY. LISTS.
SOCIAL WORKERS AND ASSOCIATES
NO CLINICAL COUNSELORS THIS
THOSE ASSOCIATES PROVIDING
EDUCATIONALLY RELATED MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES IN EDUCATION
AND CLINICAL SETTINGS IN
ESSENCE OUR SCHOOLS. THE BILL
ALSO CAPS THE CLINICAL HOURS AT
A LICENSED PROFESSIONAL
CLINICAL COUNSELOR CAN UTILIZE
TOWARDS LICENSURE AT TWELVE
HUNDRED HOURS OUT OF THE THREE
THOUSAND REQUIRED RESPECTFULLY
AS FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM IS FOR
ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SEEING
AND HEARING NONE IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION THE SUBS. A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING AND HEARING
NON ICE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM TO SEVENTEEN SENATOR
TO RUSSELL MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN NINETY SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OBERNOLTE AN ACT
RELATING TO PROTECT OUR BORDERS
SENATOR RAWSON THANK YOU
MANAGER AB THIRTEEN NINETY SIX
WILL PREVENT ON GOING ELDER
ABUSE BY GIVING JUDGES THE
OPTION OF ORDERING A RESTRAINT
PARTY. TO ATTEND ANGER
MANAGEMENT OR CLINICAL
COUNSELING FOLLOWING THE
ISSUANCE OF AN ELDER ABUSE
RESTRAINING ORDER THE NATIONAL
COUNCIL ALL AGING REPORTS AT
APPROXIMATELY ONE IN TEN
AMERICANS AGE SIXTY PLUS HAVE
REPORTED EXPERIENCING SOME FORM
OF ELDER ABUSE. ELDER ABUSE IS
SIMILAR TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN
THAT ALMOST 6% OF ELDER ABUSE
AND NEGLECT INCIDENTS OF THE
RETREAT IS A FAMILY MEMBER.
HOWEVER IN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CASES. TOOLS ARE AVAILABLE
PREVENT RECURRENCE OF THE ABUSE
FOR THESE REASONS I WAS. ABLE.
SENATOR ROSS TWENTY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
NONE ICE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM TO EIGHTEEN SENATOR
PAM MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX NINETY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING
AN ACT RELATING TO POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION SENATOR PAM
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS ON PLEASE 2% EIGHTY
SIX NINE SEVEN SUMMER TAKING.
REGARDING ADMISSIONS THE
COLLEGE ADMISSIONS SCANDAL
HIGHLIGHTS TWO DIFFERENT PATHS
TO A COLLEGE DEGREE ONE FOR
WELL CONNECTED FAMILIES AND
ANOTHER FOR THE REST OF
CALIFORNIANS. KURT EMISSIONS
PRAC GIVE PREFERENCE TO
STUDENTS RELATED TO SCHOOLS
DONORS AN ALUMNI ONLY
EXACERBATES THIS INEQUALITY WE
MUST HELP LEVEL THE PLAYING
FIELD NOT VERY LEASE PROVIDE
MORE DISCLOSURE SO THAT
STUDENTS AND PARENTS HAVE
GREATER INSIGHT INTO THE
APPLICATION PROCESS. EIGHTY SIX
NINETY SEVEN ARTS COLLEGES
REPORT THE LEGISLATURE WHETHER
GRANTS PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT
TO STUDENTS RELATED TO DONORS
ALUMNI AND IF SO REQUIRES
FURTHER DISCLOSURE REGARDING
HOW MANY STUDENTS ARE BEING
ADMITTED UNDER SUCH
CIRCUMSTANCES. THIS BILLS BEEN
FOUND HAVE NEGLIGIBLE CAUGHT
THE STATE RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT INCLUDED ASSEMBLY NO NO
VOTES THERE'S NO FORMAL
OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU DOCTOR
PAN INSERTED DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES BELL I PURCHASED
BRADFORD I CABALLERO. CHIANG I
DALY DOT HI DORADO I GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG I HILL AYE HUESO. I
TITLE. JACKSON JONES. NO LEYVA
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL. HI MONNING
I'M MORE LOCKED MORALE NO
NIELSEN. I PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER
I STERN. BY STONE NO NUMBER. I
HAVE A CASSIE AYE WIENER AYE
WILK. HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BATES GORGEOUS.
CABALLERO DALY. GROWTH TALA.
JACKSON HI BY LEYVA MORE LOCK.
WILK I TO KNOW. I TWENTY EIGHT
WAS FOR THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ALONG NOW TO FILE ITEM
TO NINETEEN. SENATOR DOLLY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DOLLY PLEASE
READ MISTER SECTOR ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT FORTY BY THEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DELI AND ACT
REALLY INTO COLOR BEVERAGES. IF
YOU GO TO FOR THREE THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT TODAY IN
PRESENTING BILL IT AB EIGHT
FORTY RELATED TO THE CAL THE
RESORT AND CASINO IN LAKE TAHOE
AREA OF KINGS BEACH CALIFORNIA
IN MY DISTRICT AND CRYSTAL BAY
NEVADA. THIS RESOURCE STRADDLES
THE CALIFORNIA NEVADA BORDER
WHICH MAKES IT VERY UNIQUE THIS
BILL SIMPLY SEEK TO CREATE A
NARAL LICENSE TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF ALCOHOL USE WITHIN
REPORTS AS PART OF IT IS IN
CALIFORNIA AND HISTORICALLY THE
LIQUOR LICENSE HAS BEEN COME
FROM NEVADA. I WORK CLOSELY
WITH ALCOHOL BEVERAGE CONTROL
BOARD TO SURE WE HAVE THE MOST
ACCURATE LANGUAGE THIS BILL. AS
ENJOYING AS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
I RESPECTFULLY OPT FOR NINE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION THIS FOR
ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE IS TURNING OBJECTION IS
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING AND HEARING NONE I
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
TO TWENTY SENATOR RUBIO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALMOST AN ACT RELATING
TO PEOPLE'S. UNDER RUBIO THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT AB. THIRTY FOUR
EIGHTY THIRTY FOUR SIX TO UNIFY
STATE AND LOCAL ANTI BULLYING
RESOURCES ONTO A SINGLE LAND
LANDING PAGE EASILY ACCESSIBLE
TO PARENTS AND STUDENTS SEEKING
OUT HELP FROM THEIR SCHOOLS AND
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS. THIS
BILL WILL BUILD ON THE WORK OF
THE LEGISLATURE ON CONTINUING
THE PROCESS OF ANTI BULLYING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE THANK YOU. THIRTY DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM ANY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON FILE
ITEM TO TWENTY SEEING AND
HEARING NONE. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION IS SUBSTITUTING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
NONE OUR EYES THIRTY NINE AT NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM TO TWENTY ONE
SENATOR WILK. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA AND
ACTUALLY IN THE WATER SENATOR
WILL. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS ARRIVED PERCENT AB
FIFTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA. AB
FIFTY EIGHTY EIGHT WOULD ENSURE
THAT MILITARY VETERANS
TRANSITIONING INTO CIVILIAN
WATER AND WASTEWATER OPERATOR
OCCUPATIONS RECEIVE APPROPRIATE
CREDITING FOR THE EXPERIENCE
AND EDUCATION THEY GAINED
DURING THEIR MILITARY SERVICE
RECENT FLOOR MEMBERS CLARIFY
ELLA THE ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS FOR FORMER
MILITARY SERVICE MEMBERS
SERVING ON ADVISORY COMMITTEES
THAT WILL ASSIST IN IDENTIFYING
THESE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
RECIPROCITY. THE RECENT
INDUSTRY REPORTS THOUSAND ATER
WORKERS ARE AGING AND EXPECTED
TO RETIRE FROM THEIR POSITIONS
IN THE NEXT FEW YEARS AT THE
SAME TIME MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND US MILITARY
MEMBERS LEAVE MILITARY SERVICE
EACH YEAR. MANY WITH EQUIVALENT
TECHNICAL SKILL SETS THAT MATCH
THE GROWING DEMAND FOR
EXPERIENCE WATER OPERATORS THIS
PROPERLY CREDIT THE SERVICE OF
OUR VETERANS PROVIDE THEM WITH
THE JOBS HERE IN CALIFORNIA'S
WATER SYSTEM. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR WILL CONCERNING TO
OR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM IN A
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON FILE
ITEM TO TWENTY ONE. SENATOR
CHIANG. GOOD AFTERNOON
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT AMERICA'S VETERANS HAVE
MORE TO OFFER A COUNTRY IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES LONG AFTER
THEY HAVE RETURNED HOME. DURING
THEIR SERVICE AND HAVE LEARNED
A VARIETY OF SKILLS AND TRADES
THAT ARE IN HIGH DEMAND BUT IN
SHORT SUPPLY. BY CREATING NEEDS
TO TRANSITION FROM MILITARY
SERVICE TO THE CIVILIAN
WORKFORCE OUR VETERANS CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS OPPORTUNITY
INFILL VACANT POSITIONS IN AN
IMPORTANT FIELD. CREATING A
PATHWAY FOR VETERAN FOR
QUALIFIED VETERANS PUT THEIR
SKILLS TO WORK IS THE LEAST WE
CAN DO AFTER THEY HAVE SERVED
OUR COUNTRY. I ASK YOU TO JOIN
ME IN SUPPORTING THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER SENATOR
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I SUPPORT THIS BILL
GETS ITS OPENING THE DOOR FOR
ALL VETERANS WHO ARE WORKING
EVERY SINGLE DAY IN VARIOUS
MILITARY OCCUPATIONS AND
THEY'RE CALLED MLS'S MILLET
HERE MILITARY OCCUPATIONAL
SPECIALTY TRUCK DRIVERS TO
NURSES X. RAY TECHNICIANS
MEDICS YOU NAME IT THEY ARE
DOING IT EVERY SINGLE DAY SO
THIS BILL OPENS THE DOOR TO
TAKE THAT EDUCATE THEY RECEIVED
IN THE MILITARY APPLY IT TO THE
TWO BILLION A LOT. AND WE CAN
COORDINATE WITH OUR ALLEGED
JUNIOR COLLEGES WILL ACCELERATE
THEIR CERTIFICATES THINK THEY
NEED TO START THEIR LIVES IS
BRILLIANT SO I JUST PORT THIS
BILL WILL PARTLY THANK YOU
THANK YOU SURCHARGE LETTUCE
KNITTER. WILL THING BUT-
SENATOR GROUP OF. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WHAT I'D
LIKE TO ASK ALL OF US TO THINK
MORE BROADLY WITH SERVING IN
THE MILITARY. THESE INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE TRUCK DRIVERS FOR
INSTANCE A DRY THESE MULTI
UNITS OF SUPPLY VEHICLES
THROUGH DANGEROUS TERRAIN.
THOSE SKILL SHOULD TRANSFER
OVER INTO CIVILIAN LIFE FOR A
WEEK JUST COME IN AND GET THEIR
CLASS A LOT AND WE NEED TO GO
THROUGH ALL THE PROCESSES. THE
SAME WITH IS MY CALL SAID
TEACHERS WE HAD TEACHERS THAT
TEACH ON TERRY BASES IN THESE
TEACHERS THAT. COME IN YOU KNOW
MILITARY FAMILIES MOVE FROM
PLACE TO PLACE TO PLACE TO
PLACE AND SO MAYBE HAVE A
LICENSE TO TEACH AND- YOU KNOW
COLORADO ARIZONA OR FLORIDA
BECAUSE THAT'S THE MILITARY
BASE IT. ON THIS YEAR. THEY CAN
CALIFORNIA THEY DON'T BY THE
TEACHER SO WHEN YOU. THE
TRANSFERABLE SKILLS NEAR AS DOT
THREE TECHNICIAN. TRANSFERABLE
OUR MILITARY CANNELLA.
TRANSITION TO THE OR- A FAMILY
MEMBER OR A SPOUSE OF SOMEONE
IT LATER WHERE THEY TRAVEL WITH
THAT SPELLS FROM BATES DEBATE.
AS INDIVIDUALS OFFER A VERY
HIGH QUALITY OF. EASILY THANK
YOU THANK YOU SENATOR GROVE.
SEEING NO FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SENATOR WELL LOOKS
LIKE YOU'VE GOT SOME SUPPORT IN
THIS BILL YOU MAKE I WANT TO
THANK GOD MY COLLEAGUES FOR ALL
THEIR COMMENTS IN AGAIN
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER WILL
CALL DEBATE HAVING SEE
SINCERITY OBJECTION THE
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. THERE IS OBJECTION WITH
THAT MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. ARCHULETA
I ATKINS BY BATES. I BILL I
BRIDGES I BRADFORD. I CAMBIADO
I CHIANG. HI DALY AYE DODD. HI
THERE ALSO. HI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER. I GONZALEZ BY GROWTH I
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO BY
OUR TITLE I JACKSON HI BY JONES.
BY LEYVA. MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL
AYE MONNING BY MORE LUCK I'M A
REAL HI NIELSEN. I PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN. BY STONE
BY AMBER I WOULD COUNTY. WIENER
AYE WILK HI PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN BY LEYVA
WHAT CASSIE. ICE THIRTY EIGHT
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ALONG TO FILE ITEM TO
TWENTY TWO SENATOR SKINNER
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DALY AN ACT
RELATING TO DRIVER'S LICENSES
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I THINK
MOST OFUS ARE AWARE THAT MORE
AND MORE ACCIDENTS ARE THE
RESULT OF. DISTRACTED DRIVING
AND IN FACT THE RESEARCH
INDICATES THAT TEXTING WHILE
DRIVING IF YOU ARE TEXTING
WHILE YOU'RE DRIVING YOU ARE
EIGHT TIMES MORE LIKELY TO GET
IN AN ACCIDENT WHICH MEANS THAT
ANY OF US WERE NOT TEXTING
WHILE DRIVING BART ASK FOR
THOSE WHO ARE. THE BILL WOULD.
TO MAKE OUR ROADS SAFER FOR
EVERYONE BY STRENGTHENING THE
PENALTY FOR DISTRACTED DRIVING.
IN THAT IT WOULD ADD A POINT TO
YOUR DRIVING RECORD AFTER YOUR
SECOND VIOLATION AND THEN
ADDITIONAL POINTS FOR EVERY
SUBSEQUENT. DISTRACTED DRIVING
VIOLATION THE BILL IS BI
PARTISAN SUPPORT AND I ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON FILE ITEM TO TWENTY TWO
SEEING AND HEARING NONE IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION IS
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING AND HEARING NONE I
IS THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING RIGHT
ALONG TO FILE ITEM TWO TWENTY
THREE SENATOR CAFIERO. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE THIRTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO AN ACT
RELATING TO CARE FACILITIES
CENTER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT PLEASED TO PRESENT.
THE MEMBER KANSEN CHU WHICH
WILL HELP HOMELESS YOUTH IN
NEED OF TEMPORARY SHELTER THIS
BILL SPECIFICALLY INCREASE THE
INCREASES THE NUMBER OF NIGHTS
A YOU CAN STAY AT A YOUTH
HOMELESS PREVENTION CENTER FROM
TWENTY ONE TO NINETY NIGHTS
CURRENT TWENTY ONE NIGHT RULE
EXISTS BECAUSE THE CENTERS RELY
ON FEDERAL FUNDING. TO SHELTER
YOUTH. AND IF YOUR STAY IS
MESSED THREE THE BILL ALLOWS
SHELTERS TO USE OTHER FUNDS IN
ORDER TO ALLOW THE LONGER STATE
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES AND HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR KIRBY AIR. DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM
SEEING AND HEARING NONE IS
THIRTY OBJECTION IS
SUBSTITUTING UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL SEEING AND HEARING NON ICE
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
TO TWENTY FOUR. SENATOR ON
BURKE YOUR SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN
TWENTY NINE BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS AND
REDISTRICTING AND ACT REALLY
INTO ELECTIONS SENATOR UMBERG
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE RESENT AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY
NINE MAKES MINOR CHANGE
ELECTION CODE EVERYBODY LIKES
IT BUT WE DOES NOT LIKE IT.
THERE'S NO VOTE. SHORT AND
SWEET. AND FULL OF SUB. ANY
DEBATER DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
ICE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM TO TWENTY SIX SENATOR
WIENER. SENATOR WIENER MISSED
CHERRY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN ELEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING AN ACT
RELATING TO ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES
SENATOR WINNER. I THANK YOU IN
A PRESS. I BECAUSE AB THIRTEEN
ELEVEN WAS EMBERS ENDING ON
BEHALF OF SOMEONE RETAIN IS A
DISTRICT BUILD ASSEMBLY
AUTHORIZES ABC TO ALLOW
SPECIFIED ALCOHOL BEVERAGE
LICENSES AND SAN FRANCISCO TO
BE TRANSFERRED WITHIN THE SAME
NEIGHBORHOOD I GIVEN THE HIGH
COST OF RENT FOR COMMERCIAL
SPACES IN SAN FRANCISCO.
BUSINESS OWNER ARE OFTEN FORCED
LOCATED ON FOR QUITE BECAUSE
THE TYPE EIGHTY SEVEN LYSONS
THAT WAS CREATED A FEW YEARS
AGO CANNOT TRANSFERRED TO ANY
OTHER LOCATION THESE
ENTREPRENEURS CAN GO OUT OF
BUSINESS AND LOSE THEIR TYPE
EIGHTY SEVEN LICENSE. THE BILL
SURE IS THAT IT. THIS IS FORCED
TO RELOCATE TO ON FOR.
CIRCUMSTANCES TO THE RIGHT
INCREASE. THAT THEY CAN I
TRANSFER THE TYPE EIGHTY SEVEN
LICENSE TO THE NEW BUSINESS
LOCATION AS LONG AS IT'S WITHIN
THE SAME NEIGHBORHOOD. AB
THIRTEEN ELEVEN RETAINS ALL THE
EXISTING CONDITIONS AND
RESTRICTIONS REQUIRED BY ABC
INCLUDING THE NON TRANSFER
ABILITY TO ANOTHER OWNER. IS A
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE
REGULATIONS. THIS BILL ALLOWS
LICENSEES TO MOVE WITHIN
NEIGHBORHOOD BOUNDARIES IT HAS
THE SUPPORT OF THE CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO OF THE MAYOR LONDON
BREED I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
RIVAL. DEBATE OR DISCUSSION IS
FOR A DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
FILE ITEM TO TWENTY SIX
THINKING HEARING NONE IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
NONE RE AS THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM TO
TWENTY EIGHT SENATOR GALGIANI
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT THIRTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY
AND ACTUALLY INTO VEHICLES
INCLUDING THE URGE THEY'RE UP
TO TAKE EFFECT IMEDIATELY
CENTER GALGIANI THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS AB EIGHT. THREE
CLARIFIES EXISTING LAW
REGARDING ELIGIBILITY TO THE
PARKING CITATION MONTHLY
PAYMENT PLAN CREATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THE PAYMENT PLAN WAS
ESTABLISHED FOR LOW INCOME
DRIVERS. AND CONSISTED OF AN
ENROLLMENT FEE OF NO MORE THAN
FIVE DOLLARS AND MONTHLY
INSTALLMENTS OF NO MORE THAN
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS FOR
EIGHTEEN MONTHS. THE CITATIONS
IF A PERSON RECEIVED MORE THAN
ONE COULD NOT AGGREGATE AMOUNT
MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS
UNDER THE PREVIOUS BILL AND
LATE FEES AND PENALTIES
SPECIMENS WERE TO BE WAIVED
ACCORDING TO AB FIVE A THREE
THE PREVIOUS SPELL. SOME CITIES
HOWEVER ARE CALCULATING THE
EASE OF THE CITATION LATE FEES
AND PENALTIES ASSESSMENTS INTO
THE THREE HUNDRED DOLLAR CAP
WHICH SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCES
ACCESS THE PAYMENT PLAN. BE
EIGHT THIRTY THREE ADDRESSES
THIS ISSUE CLARIFY. FEES AND
PENALTY ASSESSMENT NOT ONLY
WAIT ONCE INVOLVED IN TO THE
PAYMENT PLAN BUT ARE NOT BE
CALCULATED INTO THE THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS AB. YOU TO
DETERMINE ELIGIBILITY FOR THE
PAYMENT. HAS BY PART. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU CENTER GALGIANI
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
OUR ICE THE EXCUSE ME ANY SUCH
ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE ICE THIRTY NINE
KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE URGENCY ICE
THIRTY NINE TWO ZERO ON THE
MEASURE THE MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM TO TWENTY NINE. SENATOR
HILL. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL A TWENTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN
AN ACT RELATING TO THE SAN
MATEO COUNTY FLOOD AND SEA
LEVEL RISE RESILIENCY DISTRICT.
SENATOR HILL THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THAT WHILE SOME
COMMUNITIES MAY THINK OF SEA
LEVEL RISE AS AN INCONVENIENT
REALITY OF THE DISTANT FUTURE.
THIS IS NOT THE CASE FOR MY
DISTRICT IN MATTEO COUNTY SAN
MATEO COUNTY HAS MORE PEOPLE
AND PROPERTY VALUE AT RISK FROM
RISING SEA LEVELS THAN ANY
OTHER COUNTY IN THE STATE.
WHILE MANY EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
THE THREAT OF SEA LEVEL RISE
ARE UNDER WAY CEMETERY COUNTIES
TWENTY CITIES NEED A
COORDINATED APPROACH TO
ADEQUATELY PREPARE FOR THESE
THREATS ACROSS THE COUNTY. AS A
WHOLE AB TWENTY FIVE WOULD
MODIFY THE EXISTING SAN MATEO
COUNTY FLOOD CONTROL DISTRICT
THE NAME. SINCE DOUBLE RISE
RESILIENCY AGENCY THE AGENCY
LIKE THE EXISTING FOR. FCD
WOULD BE A COUNTY WIDE SPECIAL
DISTRICT THIS MODIFIED LOCAL
ENTITY WOULD BE TASKED WITH
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSING
FLOODING COASTAL EROSION AND
SEA LEVEL RISE TO BEST
PROTECTED PREPARE THE COUNTY.
COMMUNITIES IN INFRASTRUCTURE
THIS MEASURE HAS RECEIVE
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
HAS NO OPPOSITION PERFECTLY
AFTER UP CUP. THANK YOU SENATOR
HILL DEBATER DESCRIPTION ON
THIS ITEM SEEING AND HEARING
NONE. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN I ARCHULETA
I ATKINS AYE BATES NO BILL I
PURCHASED. EFFORT I CABALLERO I
CHIANG I DALY. DOT. BY THE RISE
OF AYE GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG I
HILL AYE HUESO HI TITLE I
JACKSON HI BY JONES. NO LEYVA
MCGUIRE. HI MITCHELL BY MORNING
BY MORE LOCK HI MORRELL NO
NIELSEN NO PAN. BY PORTANTINO I
ROTH AYE RUBIO. SKINNER BY
STERN AYE STONE NOVEMBER I
WOULD COUNTY I WINNER. BY WILK
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. FOR JUST. DALLY GROWTH
LEYVA RUBIO HI. OUR EYES THIRTY
ONE KNOWS FIVE THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM TO THIRTY NINE.
SENATOR PORTANTINO. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX FORTY FIVE BY SEVEN
NUMBER WHEN AN ACRONYM FARMS
SENATOR PORTANTINO FLOORS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT A
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT AB
SIX FORTY FIVE WHICH REQUIRES
THE POSTING OF THE NATIONAL
SUICIDE PREVENTION LIFELINE ON
EXISTING LABELS ON GUN
PACKAGING ON THE FIREARM SAFETY
CERTIFICATE EXAM AND I NEW
SIGNS IN GUN SHOPS THERE'S BEEN
A STARTLING INCREASE OF
FIREARMS SUICIDES IN CALIFORNIA
AND CURRENTLY THERE IS NO
MANDATED INFORMATION ON SUICIDE
PREVENTION RESOURCES AT ANY
POINT. DURING THE PROCESS OF IT
OBTAINING A FIREARM SB SIX
FORTY FIVE WILL PROVIDE GREATER
ACCESS TO INFORMATION THAT CAN
ASSIST IN INDIVIDUAL IN CRISIS
WHEN YOU LOOK UNDER REASONABLE
FIREARM LEGISLATION THIS
PICTURE IS IN THE DICTIONARY
BECAUSE JUST REQUIRING
INFORMATION WHEN YOU PURCHASE A
GUN SHOULD BE MANDATED TO
PREVENT SUICIDE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SIR
PORTANTINO'S HER EIGHT OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. BY OUR TO THAT A AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES. BELL I
PURCHASED HI. GORGEOUS NO.
BRADFORD BY CABALLERO HI JANE.
DALLY. DODD AYE AYE TERRAZZO. I
GALGIANI I GLAZER. I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI BY HILL
AYE HUESO BY TITLE I JACKSON.
HI JONES NO LEYVA MCGUIRE BY
MITCHELL. BY MONEY I'M MORE
LARGE MORRELL NO NIELSEN BY PAN
I PORTANTINO BY ROTH. BY RUBIO
I SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE.
NOVEMBER OUR CASKEY I WINNER I
WILK. PLEASE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BATES. CHIANG
DELHI. GROWTH LEYVA MORE LOCK
WILK. OUR EYES TWENTY NINE
KNOWS FOR THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE HAVE GONE THROUGH THE FILE
ONCE WE HAVE THREE ITEMS
SENATOR MCGUIRE WILL BE
PRESENTING STARTING WITH FILE
ITEM TEN THEY WON TWENTY SIX
THAN ONE SEVENTY SEVEN. I'M
SORRY ONE TEN ONE TWENTY SIX
AND ONE SEVENTY SEVEN THEN WE
WILL LIFT THE CALLS ON THE
MATTERS THAT HAVE BEEN PLACED
ON CALL SO WITH FACT FILE ITEM
ONE TEN COLLEAGUES MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ A SOME OF
THOSE SEVEN FORTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD AN ACT
RELATING TO BEER MANUFACTURES.
SENATOR MCGUIRE THANK YOU SO
MUCH BETTER PRESIDENT WHO
DOESN'T LIKE CRAFT BREWING AND
I COULD BE IN A PRISON EIGHTY
SEVEN FORTY SIX ON BEHALF OF
THE NORTH COAST ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IS STILL NEVER WOULD THIS IS A
NON CONTROVERSIAL BILL THAT AT
SOME BODIES. EXISTING LAW TO
ENSURE THAT THE HOLDER OF A
BEER MANUFACTURES LICENSE
ENJOYS THE SAME FLEXIBILITY
WITH REGARD TO THE SHERMAN FOOD
DRUG AND COSMETIC LAW AS WINE
GROWERS. AND WINE BLENDERS THIS
IS A BIPARTISAN BILL.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. IS THERE ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE I THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL FOR THE YEAR SEEING AND
HEARING NONE BUYS THIRTY NINE
NO ZERO ASSEMBLY EXCUSE ME THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY SIX. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
SIXTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURKE AN ACT RELATING TO
TAXATION. SENATOR MCGUIRE THANK
YOU SO MUCH BETTER PRESIDENT
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT A. B. TWO
SIXTY THREE INCREASE EIGHT ALL
THE HARD WORK BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BURKE. EXISTING LAW REQUIRES
THAT ALL NEW TAX CREDITS
CONTAINS SPECIFIC GOALS AND
PURPOSES AND OBJECTIVES ALONG
WITH DETAIL PERFORMANCE
INDICATORS FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO USE WHEN EVALUATING THE TAX
CREDITS EFFECTIVENESS. THIS
BILL WILL SIMPLY EXPAND
EXISTING REQUIREMENTS TO ALL
TAX EXPENDITURES UNDER THE
PERSONAL INCOME TAX LAW THE TAX
CORPORATION. IN THE SALES AND
USE TAX LAW THIS BILL HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT HAS NOT
RECEIVED A SINGLE NO VOTE
ORDERS ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
IS ARE ANY OBJECTIONS
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING AND HEARING ON ICE
THIRTY NINE ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. THE FINALIZED ON THE
DAILY FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
THREE. ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
EIGHTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND NOT GOING TO
COMMUNICATIONS. SENATOR MCGUIRE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE MADAM PRESIDENT
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT IS
IMPORTANT BILL BY THE GOOD
ASSEMBLY WOMAN WHICH WILL ADD
THE SECRETARY OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LIBRARIAN AND THE
GOVERNOR'S TRAVEL ADVISOR TO
THE CALIFORNIA BROADBAND
COUNCIL THIS BILL IS PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY ADDISON ENERGY
UTILITIES. AND COMMUNICATIONS
COMMITTEE NO NO VOTES WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR MCGUIRE
ANY DEBATE QUESTION ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
ICE THIRTY NINE AT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES WE ARE NOW GOING
TO GO BACK AND LIVE THE CALLS
ON THE SEVERAL ITEMS THAT WERE
PLACED ON CALL. WE'LL GO
THROUGH THEM IF WE COULD PLEASE
EVERYONE IN THEIR SEATS GO ONE
TIME AND THEN WE WILL BE ABLE
TO. COMPLETE THIS EFFORT TO AND
BE OUT OF HERE IN FAIRLY SHORT
ORDER. SO WE WILL START WITH
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY ONE. AB
FIFTY SEVEN MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CHIANG. GROVE GROW BY. LEYVA
MCGUIRE AYE MORALE. STONE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE MORE TIME PLEASE CHIANG.
LEYVA MERRELL. STONE OUR EYES
THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
THREE AB ONE TWO THREE SEVEN
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
JONES I LEYVA. MCGUIRE HI HIGHS
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY A.
B. NINE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. LEYVA
MCGUIRE. PRICE THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO IN THE URGENCY ICE THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO ON THE MEASURE
FILE ITEM. ONE SEVENTY SIX
EIGHTY FOUR NINETY SEVEN PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS LEYVA.
MCGUIRE HIGH MORALE. VICE
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY ICE THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO ON THE MEASURE THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY. AB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS LEYVA
MCGUIRE BY. I THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON A BEFORE
TWELVE. GROW HI. LEYVA MCGUIRE
AYE AYES THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY TWO AB NINE TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. LEYVA MCGUIRE BY ICE
THIRTY NINE TWO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY THREE AB ONE TWO THREE
FOUR. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS LEYVA MCGUIRE BY FIVE
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN. AB FIFTEEN TWENTY NINE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
GROVE. HI LEYVA MCGUIRE AYE
MORRELL. ICE THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO ON THE URGENCY ICE THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO ON THE MEASURE
THE MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY NINE AB TWO SIXTY
SEVEN. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS LEYVA MCGUIRE HI. OUR
EYES THE THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
ONE NINETY. AB THIRTEEN THIRTY
THREE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BRADFORD. HI. LEYVA
MCGUIRE I. ICE THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE NINETY SIX. AB NINE
TWELVE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. GROWTH HI LEYVA.
MCGUIRE HI ICE THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES AND
FINALLY FILE ITEM ONE NINETY
SEVEN AB NINE TWENTY THREE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
LEYVA MCGUIRE HI. OUR EYES
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. AT THIS POINT TIME WE
WILL GO TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
AT THIS AT THIS POINT IF
THERE'S ANYONE THAT WISHES TO
TAKE AN ITEM OFF THE CALENDAR.
PLEASE SO NOTE. SEEING NONE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE. CALL
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR SIXTIES AGREED THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SOME OF THE
FOUR SIXTY SIX EIGHT NINETY TWO
NINE OH TWO AND A SOME OF THE
FIFTEEN SEVENTY THREE. ON THE
FIRST ITEM FILE ITEM TO FORTY
SEVEN. IS. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO APPLYING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NON. I THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR PASSES.
MOVING NOW TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. SENATOR HER
TITLE I REYES FOR PURPOSES OF
ANNOUNCEMENT THE SENATE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE WILL BE
MEETING UP FIFTEEN MINUTES UPON
THE END OF SESSION IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FROM TWENTY FORTY
THE HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE OF
FIFTEEN MINUTES AFTER THE
CONCLUSION OF SESSION NOW WE'RE
GOING TO RETURN TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THIS IS THE TIME TO
ADJOURN. IN MEMORY. THE US
SENATOR NIELSEN DID YOU HAVE AN
INTERN IN MEMORY. MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THE SENATE IT WAS A WITH THE
HAVE VERY HEAVY HEART I. ASKED
WE ADJOURN TODAY IN MEMORY OF
ROSEVILLE POLICE OFFICER
CAMERON CAM LANDON. CAN LAND
AND WENT TO SLEEP THE OTHER
NIGHT. WENT ON TO HAVE A. THE
GREAT LAS RICH FAMILY. A TRUE
HERO. HE WENT TO. NEVADA UNION.
WHAT ON THE COLLEGE. THERE'S
ACTUALLY NO WAY TO SANTA
BARBARA. COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
LATER ON DURING HIS TENURE AS A
DEPUTY SHERIFF HE SECURED A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN CRIMINAL
JUSTICE. AND PURSUED THAT
CAREER. HE THEN FROM. THE
COUNTY WENT TO THE CITY OF
ROSEVILLE. SERVE NOBODY THERE.
WHAT'S INTERESTING SOME OF HIS
COLLEAGUES HIS PEERS ONE OF
WHOM WAS HERE MOST OF THE DAY
TODAY. STANDING WITH HIS FAMILY.
CALLED CAMERA FELLOW WITH A
HUGE HEART. THE HANDSOME SMILE
AN AMAZING ABILITY THE C. GOOD
AND EVERYTHING. I NEVER HAVE
THE PLEASURE OF MEETING CÃM.
SEEING HIS PICTURE THAN GETTING
ACQUAINTED WITH HIS FAMILY HERE
TODAY. I CAN SEE WHERE THOSE
TRAITS WE'RE BOUNTIFULLY
PRESENT IN HIM. IT WAS IN THE
UNITED STATES MARINES. SERVED
IN IRAQ. NICK SPENT SOME TIME
IN AUSTRALIA. WHERE HE MET HIS
WIFE. ANGELA. ANGELA'S FATHER
AND MOTHER ON AND THERESA HAD
BEEN WITH US HERE TODAY TO.
THEY FASHION TO THE TRUE GREAT
LOVE. AND TWO CHILDREN HAVE
BEEN BORN. YOUNG WHY AND WHO IS
FOR AND WESTERN WHO IS TO. AND
THE THIRD CHILD. WILL BE COMING
IN A WHILE. THE SAD THAT THAT
YOUNG CHILD WOULD NOT GET TO
KNOW HIS MOTHER. WHY IT
CERTAINLY DOES KNOW HIS FATHER
THOUGH. AND YOUR KNOWLEDGE
MEANT. THE FATHER HERE TODAY
WE'LL PUT A MEMORY. THE WHOLE
FOURTH FOREVER IN THEIR MINDS
ONE DAY WHEN THEY LOOK AT THE
SENATE JOURNAL. OVER THE
MEMORIAL RESOLUTION THAT WE
PRESENTED THE FAMILY WITH IT
THANK KNOWLEDGE. THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. THEY'RE
COURAGEOUS BRAVE AND LOVING
FATHER. THE GOOD REASON LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN WHY WE DO THESE
THINGS. SOME PEOPLE SAY OH IT'S
JUST KIND OF A HOLLOW GESTURE I
DON'T THINK SO. IT HAS THE FULL
WEIGHT OF ALL OF US. SUPPORTING
THE FAMILY. THOSE WHO'VE LOST A
LOVED ONE. AND THEREFORE IT HAS
SOCIETAL VALUE. IN ITSELF. HIS
MOTHER CAMERAS MOTHER CYNTHIA
HIS DECEASED. BUT HIS FATHER
JOHN AND HIS STEP MOTHER
VALERIE. WE'RE HERE WITH US
TODAY ALSO. I ASK THAT WE- SAY
SOME PRAYERS FOR THIS FAMILY.
FOR THAT BRAVE WARRIOR AND
PUBLIC SERVANT. WHO CONTINUED
TO GIVE OF HIMSELF. FOR ALL OF
US. IN A VERY TOUGH JOB.
INCREASED FAMILY WHO LOVED HIM
AND- HAD HIM TAKEN AWAY ALL TOO
HASTILY. IN A SHOCKING MENIER
MANNER. THEY THEY BE COMFORTED.
BUT THE ENJOY OUR PRAYERS. AND
CAMERON. MAY YOU BE WITH GOD.
AB SERVING HIM AND HAVE A. I
ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN AND
CAMERON'S LANDON'S MEMORY TODAY
THANK YOU SENATOR NIELSEN AND
OF COURSE TO THE FAMILY AND TO
ALL WHO WERE AFFECTED BY HIS
PRESENCE WE DO EXTEND THE FULL
SYMPATHIES FOR THIS HOUSE THANK
IS. NEXT THE. PRESIDENT PRO TEM
ATKINS I BELIEVE HE WILL. I'M
SORRY DID. IS THERE ANYONE TO
WHO WISHES TO ADJOURN IN ALSO
IN THE MEMORY OF OUR. OFFICER
I'M SO SORRY EXCUSE ME DOLLY
THE FLOOR SHORES THANK YOU
pMADAM PRESIDENT I ALSO HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. A REPRESENT
CAMERA AND HE LIVED IN NEVADA
COUNTY SO OFFICER LAND IN A
ROSE WILL POLICE DEPARTMENT
TRAGICALLY PASSED AWAY AS YOU
HEARD IN HIS SLEEP JULY
SIXTEENTH TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
AT HIS HOME. OFFICER LANDON HAD
TIES TO THE NEW TO NEVADA
COUNTY WHERE HE GREW UP AND
pATTENDED ABOUT A UNION HIGH
SCHOOL AND LATER GRADUATED IN
TWO THOUSAND ONE. HE PURSUED A
DEGREE IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF PHOENIX. CAM
AND ALSO. SERVED HIS COUNTRY IN
THE MARINE CORPS FROM
200-052-2000 NINE INCLUDING A
TOUR IN IRAQ. KIM BEGAN HIS LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAREER AS A
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER. WITH THE
NEVADA COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE
THEN LATER JOINED THE GRASS
VALLEY POLICE DEPARTMENT WHERE
HE WORKED FROM TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN TO TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN AS A POLICE OFFICER AND
A MEMBER OF THE SWAT TEAM
BEFORE MOVING TO ROSE BILL TO
BEGIN HIS CAREER WITH ROSE BILL
POLICE DEPARTMENT. CAM IS
REMEMBERED BY HIS FELLOW
OFFICERS AND FRIENDS AS A FUN
LOVING DEPENDABLE GUY. WHO IS
HAPPIEST WHEN HE WAS WITH HIS
FAMILY. CAMERA IS SURVIVED BY
HIS WIFE ANGELA SONSWHY IT AND
WESTON. AND HAD A BABY ON THE
WAY. MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
A JOURNEY IN THE MEMORY OF
OFFICER KAMAN LANDED. AND KEEP
HIS FAMILY AND FRIENDS IN YOUR
THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS DURING
THIS DIFFICULT TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR DALLYING
AGAIN CONDOLENCES TO THE LANDED
FAMILY AND IF YOU WOULD BRING
HIS NAME FORWARD SO WE CAN BE
ASSURED TO PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE
HIM THAT WOULD BE APPRECIATED.
SENATOR ATKINS THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
I RISE TO A JUROR IN MEMORY. OF
CROSS CO MOLINA AND RICK IS THE
PICK. SHE PASSED AWAY ON AUGUST
ELEVENTH AT THE AGE OF NINETY
ONE. GARCIA WAS A DEDICATED
EDUCATOR CHAMPION OF HUMAN
RIGHTS A DIE HARD FEMINISTS IN
LIFELONG COMMUNITY AND CIVIL
RIGHTS ACTIVIST. SHE WAS AN
INSPIRING PRESENCE IN LEADER IN
OUR SAN DIEGO COMMUNITY WHERE
THEY WERE THERE ARE SIX
CELEBRATIONS OF LIFE BEING HELD
IN HER HONOR. SHE WOULD LOVE
THAT THAT CERTAINLY SIGNALS
IMMENSE IMPACT THIS GREAT WOMAN
HAD AND SO MANY OF OUR LIVES.
GRASSY WAS BORN IN NINETEEN
TWENTY EIGHT AND MORALE YEAH
MEXICO INTO A POLITICALLY
ACTIVE FAMILY. AND JUST
EIGHTEEN SHE WENT TO PARIS TO
ATTEND THE NINETEEN FORTY SIX
FOUNDING OF THE CONGRESS OF THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
SOCIALIST YOUTH SHE HELP
REBUILD YUGOSLAVIA'S RAILROADS.
SHE MET THE SAN DIEGANS RICHARD
PICK IN MEXICO CITY IN THE
NINETEEN FIFTIES AND THEY CAME
TO THE U. S. WHERE THE TWO WERE
MARRIED. SHE EARNED A BACHELOR
AND A MASTER OF ARTS DEGREE IN
SPANISH LANGUAGE FROM SAN DIEGO
STATE UNIVERSITY AND TAUGHT
JUNIOR HIGH IN NATIONAL CITY.
MANY OF THE MEXICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS THERE WERE BEING
PLACED IN SPECIAL EDUCATION.
BECAUSE SPANISH WAS THEIR FIRST
LANGUAGE. SEEING THAT DISPARITY
GRASSY ORGANIZE PARENTS THERE
TO FIGHT FOR BETTER EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEIR
CHILDREN. AS THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT SWELLED INTO THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES CROSS HERE WAS
AN INTEGRAL PART OF
ESTABLISHING THE NATION'S FIRST
ASSOCIATES DEGREE IN CHICANO
STUDIES AT MESA COLLEGE WHERE
SHE BECAME A FACULTY MEMBER.
GARCIA WAS ALSO A FOUNDING
FACULTY MEMBER OF THE THURGOOD
MARSHALL COLLEGE AT THE AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
DIEGO AND CONTINUE TO WORK IN
BILINGUAL EDUCATION REFORM
WHILE ALSO FOUNDING IN SERVING
ON NUMEROUS BOARDS AND
ORGANIZATIONS DEDICATED TO
FEMINISM. CHICANO RIGHTS CIVIL
RIGHTS AND LABOR REFORM. HER
PROFESSIONAL ACCOMPLISHMENTS
WERE VAST AND INCLUDED HAVING
BEEN THE FIRST SAN DIEGANS
APPOINTED TO THE CALIFORNIA
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
COMMISSION. SHE WAS ALSO NAMED
ONE OF OUR CALIFORNIA'S WOMEN
OF THE YEAR IN TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND TO. GARCIA WAS A
PHILANTHROPIST SHE GAVE
ABUNDANTLY TO OUR SAN DIEGO
COMMUNITY SHE ESTABLISHED AN
ENDOWMENT FOR THE LOGAN HEIGHTS
BRANCH LIBRARY ONE OF OUR- MOST
INNER CITY COMMUNITIES. HER OUR
CASSEROLE PERSONAL ARCHIVES.
LIBRARY AND ART TO LECTURE IN
OUR HOUSE IN THE SPECIAL
COLLECTION UNIT OF SAN DIEGO
STATE UNIVERSITY'S LIBRARY IT
WAS WONDERFUL TO BE AT THAT
SPECIAL OF IN A NUMBER OF YEARS
AGO. AS CROSS YOU ONCE. MEANING
IF YOU UNSELFISHLY ENGAGE AS
SISTERS AND BROTHERS IN THE
FIGHT FOR EQUALITY JUSTICE AND
PEACE SHE EXEMPLIFIED HER OWN
WORDS IN HER LEGACY CONTINUES
TO INSPIRE US ALL YOU KNOW LAST
WEEK WHEN WE ACKNOWLEDGED FRANK
FACTS FAMILY AND I MENTION TOM
FAT AND I SAID TOM FAT WAS ONE
OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT YOU
HAVE TO IT'S A RITE OF PASSAGE
TO GET THEIR SUPPORT AND THEIR-
APPROVAL. GARCIA AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO WILL
ADD TO THAT WAS ALSO ONE OF
THOSE PEOPLE. SHE WAS SOMEONE
WHO HAD A SENSE OF HUMOR AT. A
TWINKLE IN HER EYES. MISTY VS
BEHIND IT ALL BUT DEADLY
SERIOUS WHEN IT CAME TO THE
RIGHTS OF PEOPLE EQUAL RIGHTS.
AND SHE WAS ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE
THAT. THAT EVERYONE JUST LOVE
TO BE IN HER PRESENCE SHE WAS
SHE HAD STORIES OF REVOLUTION
SHE HAD STORIES. YOU COULD JUST.
REALLY ENJOY HER FOR HOURS AND
HOURS AND SHE IS GOING TO BE
INCREDIBLY MIST BY SO MANY NOT
JUST IN SAN DIEGO AND HER
IMPACT WILL BE FELT. I THINK OF
FOR GENERATIONS TO COME SO
PLEASE JOIN ME IN HONORING THE
MEMORY OF CROSS YOUR MOLINA AND
RICK IS TO PICK. THANK YOU
SENATOR ATKINS OBVIOUSLY A VERY
IMPORTANT PERSON TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN IN SAN DIEGO. SENATOR
HUESO ON THIS JOURNEY MEMORY. I
HAVE ANOTHER ONE BUT I DID WANT
TO ADD TO THIS I WAS AT HER.
CEREMONY OF LIFE YESTERDAY AND-
JUST SO MANY PEOPLE FROM MY
NEIGHBORHOOD. CAME OUT TO PAY
THEIR RESPECTS. AND I JUST ECHO
THE SENTIMENTS THAT OR OR PRO
TERM SHARE TODAY I JUST I JUST
WANT TO ADD THAT IT SEEMED.
THAT EVERYWHERE I WENT IN. LIFE
SHE HAD ALREADY BEEN. THAT
THOSE. THAT EXPERIENCE WAS VERY
IMPACTFUL THAT SHE WAS A VERYA
LARGE WOMAN AND THE WAY SHE
CONDUCTED HERSELF THE WAY SHE
HELP PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS ENORMOUS HEART AND WHEN
YOU MET HER YOU COULD FEEL. HER
LOVE. WE'RE GONNA MISS HER VERY
MUCH THANK YOU SENATOR REYES.
WE WILL COME BACK TO A SHORTLY
BUT NOW YOU'RE GOING TO GO TO
SENATOR DOROS SO. OF FOR HER
ADJOURNMENT ME SENATOR THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. IT IS WITH
SADNESS THAT I ASK YOU TO JOIN
IN THE MEMORY OF MY DEAR FRIEND
BARBARA TAURUS. ALTHOUGH BARBER
PASSED FAR TOO YOUNG AT THE AGE
OF THIRTY NINE. HE LEAVES
BEHIND A LEGACY OF SERVICE AND
UNWAVERING DEDICATION. TO THE
PEOPLE OF LOS ANGELES. HE WAS
BORN TO A WORKING CLASS FAMILY
IN EAST LA. AND SHE WAS SO
PROUD OF ALWAYS SAYING HE WAS
FROM EASE THE LA. TO LIVE THE
STRUGGLES FACED BY SO MANY IN
HER COMMUNITY. HE SPENT ALMOST
TWENTY YEARS AS A SPECIAL
EDUCATION PARA PROFESSIONAL
WITH THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT BECAUSE YOU
BELIEVE THAT EVERY CHILD. HAD
TO BE TREATED HAD TO BE TREATED
WITH RESPECT AND DIGNITY. LABOR
ACTIVISM BECAME HER NEXT
CALLING HE SERVED AS PRESIDENT
OF THE SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION LOCAL
NINETY NINE OF THE LIGHT THE LA
UNIFIED CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES HE
WAS THE YOUNGEST AND FIRST LET
THE IN A PRESIDENT. IN THE
CHAPTERS HISTORY HE BELIEVED IN
THE DIGNITY OF WORK SHE
ADVOCATED FOR PAY EQUITY. AND
GREATER ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
AND EDUCATION FOR THE FORTY
FIVE THOUSAND EDUCATION WORKERS
THAT SHE REPRESENTED. BARBARA
HELPED A LOT AN INCREASE IN THE
MINIMUM WAGE TO FIFTEEN DOLLARS
AN HOUR AND SECURED HELP.
FOUGHT TO GET WAGE INCREASES
FOR ALL CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
RECENTLY SHE WAS ELECTED TO THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS FOR THE LA
COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY. HE WAS
AN UNDERDOG BUT SHE NEVER
WAVERED IN HER CRUSADE TO LIFT
UP HER COMMUNITY. FOR HER
TIRELESS WORK THE CALIFORNIA
LET THE NO LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS
HONORED HER WITH THE
ACHIEVEMENT PUBLIC SERVICE
AWARD IN TWENTY SIXTEEN. HE
LEAVES BEHIND A COMMUNITY IN
THE FAMILY WHO MEANT EVERYTHING
TO HER AND TO WHOM SHE GAVE
EVERYTHING. SHE WAS A DEAR
FRIEND OF OUR ENTIRE STAFF AND
MANY MANY OF MY FRIENDS ARE
DISTRICT STAFF THE RECENTLY
RAISE TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO GIVE AWAY BACKPACKS IN HER
MEMORY. THE EAST LA CHILDREN
THAT YOU LOVE SO MUCH. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN HONORING BARBARA'S
LEGACY AND SEND IN OUR
HEARTFELT CONDOLENCES TO HER.
FAMILY HER COMMUNITY ESPECIALLY
HER TWIN SISTER AND OTHER
SISTER FRANCIS AND KATHERINE
AND HER NIECES SUSHI SPEND SO
MUCH TIME WITH THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER DRAWS SO FOR YOUR.
PRESENTATION AND- CONDOLENCES
BOTH FOR YOUR LOSS AND
CERTAINLY THE LOST TO HER
FAMILY AND TO THE CHILDREN OF
THE STERLING. SENATOR STE.
PORTIONS THANK YOU VERY
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE WITH
YOU TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
SANDY MAN DO CHIEF. SHE WAS
ACTUALLY MY P. E. TEACHER IN
HIGH SCHOOL AND HELP BUILD THE
FIRST ATHLETIC PROGRAM AT A
SMALL FLEDGLING HIGH SCHOOL IN
A TOWN THAT MANY PEOPLE THOUGHT
I DIDN'T HAVE. THE GUTS TO
COMPETE. BUT SHE BROUGHT WITH
HER WHOLE FAMILY IN INTENSITY
TO. ART LET A PROGRAMS IN OUR
COMMUNITY THAT BUILT BUILT A
CULTURE AND A SPIRIT OF
CAMARADERIE THAT STILL LIVES ON
TO THIS DAY. SHE'D MADE
EVERYTHING HAPPENED HER SON WAS
THE FOOTBALL COACH HER DAUGHTER
TOOK OVER THE VOLLEYBALL
PROGRAM EVEN AFTER HER FOR HER
HOUSE BURNED DOWN IN THE FIRE.
AND SHE WAS STRUGGLING WITH
CANCER THIS PAST YEAR SHE
COMMUTED BACK ALL THE WAY FROM
HUNTINGTON BEACH TO COME BACK
TO THE CITY AND BE AN ASSISTANT
HELP WITH YOUTH SPORTS HELP
WITH RECREATION. ONE'S GOT A
SANDY BEEN DO CHI IN THEIR
COMMUNITY. SOMETIMES THEY'RE
INVISIBLE BUT ON A DAY LIKE
THIS IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THEY'RE NOT. BECAUSE THEY'RE
TRULY THE BACKBONE OF WHAT
BRINGS FAMILIES TOGETHER. AND
SPORTS AND ATHLETICS ARE NOT
JUST SPORTS AND ATHLETICS. IT'S
A PLACE FOR US TO ACTUALLY GET
OUT OF OUR STATIONS IN WHERE
EVERYBODY'S EQUAL ON THE FIELD.
AND SANDY BROUGHT THAT SHE
SURVIVED BY BRIAN ERIC AND AMY
AND HER HUSBAND ROCK A RUSS. SO
RESPECTFULLY ASK AFTER A LONG
CAREER SERVICE AND HARD WORK
AND WINNING FOR EVERYBODY THAT
WE OFFER OUR SINCERE
CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILY IN A
GERMAN. IN SANDY'S MEMORY.
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN AND
PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT YOU BRING
HER NAME FORWARD SO WE CAN
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED. BORGIAS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO JOURNEY
MEMORY OF FRESNO STATE POLICE
CHIEF ON DAVID HUERTA FOR OUR
EXTENDED FRESNO STATE FAMILY I
KNOW A LOT OF FOLKS HAVE
CONNECTIONS TO THE VALLEY THIS
INDIVIDUAL MIGHT BE KNOWN HE
CERTAINLY A VERY WELL KNOWN IN
OUR COMMUNITY. CHIEF WHERE THE
SERVED AS THE CHIEF OF THE
FRESNO STATE POLICE DEPARTMENT
BEGINNING IN AUGUST TWO
THOUSAND FOUR. RETIRED THE RANK
OF LIEUTENANT AFTER THIRTY
YEARS WITH THE FRESNO COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT. BEFORE HE
BECAME CHIEF OF THE PRESENT
STATE POLICE DEPARTMENT. WELL
WITH THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
HE RECEIVED MANY HONORS
INCLUDING A DISTINGUISHED
SERVICE MEDAL FOR HIS TWENTY
TWO PLUS YEARS OF SWAT WORK. AS
WELL AS OFFICER OF THE YEAR
FROM THE AMERICAN LEGION. CHIEF
WHERE THERE WAS AN ALUMNUS OF
FRESNO STATE IN HEAVILY
INVOLVED IN AND LOVED BY HIS
COMMUNITY. MOST IMPORTANTLY HE
DEVOTED HIS LIFE TO COMMUNITY
SERVICE AND HIS FAMILY. HIS
UNWAVERING INTEGRITY SELFLESS
DEVOTION TO PROTECTING OTHERS.
AND CAL IS CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE
CAMPUS HAVE LEFT AN
UNFORGETTABLE LEGACY IN OUR
COMMUNITY. UNDER NIELSEN CAN
ATTEST TO THIS AS WELL. CHIEF
WHERE DOES SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
CYNTHIA HIS FOUR CHILDREN
BRIONNE. ALL AUSTIN BRANDT IN
KERRIGAN IN HIS THREE
GRANDCHILDREN HE IS ALSO
SURVIVED BY HIS FATHER. WHETHER
THE BROTHER MICHAEL AND SISTER
THAT HE SAW. MAY WE ADJOURN IN
HIS MEMORY RESPECTFULLY THANK
YOU SENATOR BARGES SHIN
CERTAINLY EXTEND OUR
CONDOLENCES TO HIS FAMILY AND
PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU BRING HIS
NAME FOR IT SO WE CAN PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZE HIM. YES CENTER
NIELSEN ON THIS JOURNEY MEMORY
YES MADAM PRESIDENT PLEASE. AS
A FRESNO STATE GRADUATE AND ONE
WHO DID HAVE THE PLEASURE OF
MEETING THIS GOOD MAN. BECAUSE
OF FREQUENT TRIPS THAT I DO
MAKE TO FRESNO STATE. I'D LIKE
TO ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE CHIEF FOR A
TO. HE BROUGHT A CREDIT TO THAT
INSTITUTION BUT GREATER THAN
THAT HE BRINGS A CREDIT TO ALL
OF THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROFESSION. AND ALL OF THE
STUDENTS. WHO HIS CONDUCT AS A
CHIEF THING OVER THAT
INSTITUTION. ENSURE THE SAFE
ENVIRONMENT FOR THEIR EDUCATION.
SOME THINK THAT THE CHIEF OF A-
THE UNIVERSITY IS A EASY JOB.
WHAT'S REALLY NOT. THE CURRENT
CHIEF AT UC DAVIS IS JOE
FERRELL WHO MOST RECENTLY
HEADED THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL. IT IS A CHALLENGING JOB.
AND CHIEF WHERE TO NEW THAT.
THE PRESIDENT THE FRESNO STATE.
JOE CASTRO WAS PARTICULARLY
FOND OF HIM. ANY FIT VERY WELL
THE END IS COMMUNITY. I AM
HONORED TO STAND BEFORE YOU
TODAY AND ASKED THAT WE ALL THE
GERMAN THE MY MEMORY. OF A
TRULY GREAT SERVANT. A TRULY
GREAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROFESSIONAL. AND A TRULY GREAT
HUMAN BEING CHIEF WETA. THANK
YOU CENTER NIELSEN. SENATOR
BRADFORD. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY AND WITH
A HEAVY HEART TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF A BELOVED COMPTON
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISPROPORTIONATE
BURKE AND A DEAR FRIEND MARGIE
IN GEAR AND I'VE OF MISS GEARED
PASSED AWAY ON THE MORNING OF
JULY TWENTY SIX I'M NO MISS
GEARED FOR ALMOST FORTY YEARS
AND SHE WAS AFFECTIONATELY I
AFFECTIONATELY CALLED HER AUNT
MARGIE. SHE HAD A DISTINCT I
HAD THE DISTINCT HONOR OF
WARNER BACK INTO OFFICE AFTER A
LOSS ELECTION LAST YEAR SHE WAS
AT ABBOTT BID WAS PLAYER SHE
WAS A MOTHER A GRANDMOTHER A
WIFE AND A GREAT FRIEND HE
LOVED A PARTING SHE LOVED AS I
STATED PLAIN BID WAS MUSIC AND
DANCING HE WAS A NATIVE OF
TEXAS AND MOVED TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN NINETEEN SIXTY IN
MAKE UP THEIR HOME FOR TWO SHY
OF SIXTY YEARS AND I TAUGHT
SCHOOL IN COMPTON UNIFIED FOR
FORTY YEARS SOME SCARY SEE THE
BASSES DEGREE FROM CAL STATE
DOMINGUEZ HILLS. AND CONTINUE
TO GRADUATE AND FIFTH YEAR
STUDIES MASTER'S DEGREE PROGRAM
AT NASA UNIVERSITY AND UTILIZE
HER CAREER AS EDUCATOR BEGAN
WHEN SHE SERVED AS A NOON DUTY
EIGHT HEAD START TEACHER AND
STATE PROJECTS GO TEACHER AT
ANDERSON ELEMENTARY SCHOOL SHE
WAS ALSO A CHILD DEVELOPMENT
RESOURCE TEACHER AND PARENT
INVOLVEMENT TRAINER MISCARRY
CONTINUES TO SHORT LAW AND THE
CATION FOR THIS OF THE DISTRICT
AS A KINDERGARTEN AND PRIMARY
GRADE TEACHER AT CARVER
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL HE TOPPED OFF
THE FORTY THREE YEAR CAREER AS
A READING FIRST LITERACY COACH.
RESOURCE TEACHER HE RETIRED IN
JUNE OF TWO THOUSAND NINE FOR
MORE THAN FORTY YEARS
MISCARRIAGE HAD BEEN INVOLVED
AS A TEACHERS UNION ACTIVISTS
LEADING THE TEACHERS IN THE
ROLE AS A PRESIDENT AND VICE
PRESIDENT OF BOARD OF DIRECTORS
BARGAINING COMMITTEE
CHAIRPERSON AND AS A POLITICAL
ACTION CHAIRPERSON HE WAS A LOT
TO THE COMPANY. TO A SCHOOL
DISTRICT GOVERNING BOARD OF
TRUSTEES INTO THE. SLATE OF
REPRESENT AFTER LEADING A
COMPTON UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
LEAD TO STATE OF LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCACY EFFORTS COLLEAGUES.
EVEN IN HER LAST DAYS SHE
DEVOTED HER LIFE TO THE
COMMUNITY YOUTH THAT SHE LOVED
TO SERVE. OUR SHE CONTINUE TO
FULFILL OUR ROLE EVEN WHILE
SICK BY EVEN A REMOTELY
ATTENDING HER BOARD MEETINGS.
MEMBERS AYE HOMELY ASKED THAT
WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF MARGIE
AND GERRY A TIRELESS EDUCATOR
WHO SPENT HER LIFE EDUCATING
ENOUGH LOOKING THE KIDS OF
COMMUNITY GREATER LOS ANGELES
AREA THANK THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD AND- CERTAINLY DEEP
LOSS TO THE CHILDREN OF LA AND-
TO YOURSELF AND OTHERS WHO.
KNEW HER WELL SO. PLEASE EXTEND
THE CONDOLENCES OF THE SENATE
TO HER FAMILY AND TO HER
FRIENDS AS WELL. SENATOR HUESO
OUR LAST TO TURN IN MEMORY AND
THEN WE WILL BE ABOUT DONE
WE'RE GOING TO ASK THE WOMEN OF
THE SENATE TO STAY FOR A
PHOTOGRAPH. AFTER WE DURING
SENATOR HUESO THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
IT'S BEEN A SAID MONTH. FOR
FEMALE LEADERS IN SAN DIEGO. WE
LOST ANOTHER ONE ON. AUGUST
TWELFTH THE POLICE HAVE
GONZALEZ PASSED AWAY AUGUST
TWELFTH IN OUR HOME FILLED WITH
THEIR FAMILY OR FRIENDS I OFTEN
MADE REFERENCE TO HER ON THIS
FLOOR AS AS A BUSINESS PERSON
MY DISTRICT THAT IS. DEEPLY ARE
RESPECTED IN THE COMMUNITY AYE
AYE BROADER UP AS A SOMEBODY
WHO'S BEEN. PRACTICING MY
DISTRICT OF. YOU KNOW HELPING
THE IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY. FOR
MANY YEARS. SHE WAS BORN AND
SHE WILL MEXICO JANUARY SIXTH
NINETEEN TWENTY NINE. IN
NINETEEN FIFTY SIX SHE MOVED TO
COMPTON IN CALIFORNIA. WITH HER
YOUNGER SISTER DAUGHTER AND HER
SON ACTOR BENJAMIN. ALTHOUGH OF.
BETTER WAS WAS TIRELESS AND
DILIGENT THE SHE- SHE
CONTRACTED ASTHMA IN IN AND LOS
ANGELES AND MOVED. TO SAN DIEGO
SHE MOVED TO A CHILL OF A STERN
MY DISTRICT IN NINETEEN SIXTY
TWO AFTER RELOCATING THERE SHE
BECAME OF VERY VALUABLE MEMBER
OF THE LOCAL BUSINESS COMMUNITY
AND IN A- AND A BIG LEADER IN
THE COMMUNITY. IN NINETEEN
SIXTY TWO SHE OPENED SECONDHAND
STORE CALLED THE CALIFORNIA
POST NEXT TO THE POST OFFICE
AND SUNNY ZERO. AT THIS
LOCATION SHE SERVE THE NEEDS OF
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES AND SUIT
SOON OF. OF YOU KNOW FOUND
DIFFERENT WAYS TO SERVE THEIR
NEEDS NEEDS. IN THE IN THE
EIGHTIES SHE BECAME A NOTARY
PUBLIC AND BECAME. AND BEGAN.
UNDER UNDER UNDER CALIFORNIA
LAW THAT ALLOWED. CONSULTANTS
TO HELP PEOPLE WITH PAPERWORK
SHE- BEGAN PREPARING OF.
CITIZENSHIP APPLICATIONS FOR
MANY IMMIGRANTS IN HER LONG
CAREER SHE IS PROBABLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR HELPING TO OF.
TO PROCESS THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE AND HELP
HELP THEM GAIN THEIR
CITIZENSHIP TO THE US SHE WAS
INSTRUMENTAL FUNDING SEVERAL
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING THE
SINUS IT'LL CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
THE SENATE ZERO HEALTH CENTER
THE MAC PROJECT. THE UNITS OF
THE SUN THE SEA THE UNIVERSITY
ANALYZE FIESTA SPOT THREE US IN
SUNNY ZERO SHE ALSO DREW
STRENGTH AND SPUR OF SPIRITUAL
NOURISHMENT FROM HER DAILY
DEVOTION TO GOD FOR OVER FIFTY
YEARS SHE WAS TURN A TIRELESS
VOLUNTEER OUR LADY OF MOUNT
CARMEL. CATHOLIC CHURCH AND WAS
AN ARDENT SUPPORTER. THE WORLD
HAS BEEN ENRICHED BY THE
BLESSING COURAGE GRACE AND
PERSEVERANCE. AND LOVE BESTOWED
BY THEIR TO LISA GONZALEZ WE
WILL MISS HER VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU A CENTER HUESO OBVIOUSLY A
LOSS TO YOU AS WELL AS THE
COMMUNITY AND INDEED SAN DIEGO
HAS HAD A LITANY OF. A FULL
LEADERS WHO HAVE LEFT US THIS
PAST MONTH. WITH THAT WE ARE I
BELIEVE HAVE CONCLUDED THE
BUSINESS OF THE DAY AND IF
THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS.
SENATOR ATKINS THE DESK IS
CLEAR. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT IT'S A GREAT START TO.
THE LAST THREE WEEKS OF WORK
THAT WE GOT ACCOMPLISHED TODAY
SO TO OUR FULLER TEAM IN THE
MAJORITY LEADER THANK YOU AND
TO ALL OF YOU COLLEAGUES WE
WILL BE BACK HERE FRIDAY AUGUST
THIRTIETH AT NINE AM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR ATKINS THE
SENATE WILL BE ADJOURNED WE
RECONVENE FRIDAY AT NINE AM.
OKAY THANK YOU
SERVICES COMMITTEE WILL COME TO
ORDER WE HAVE ONE ITEM ON THE
AGENDA FOR TODAY. THAT IS EIGHT
J. R. FOURTEEN WHICH IS ON
CONSENT. AND WE HAVE A QUORUM
AS OF RIGHT NOW ALSO WE WILL.
ALL GO AHEAD AND MAKE A MOTION.
CALL ROLE. ROLL THE GUEST WE
WILL GO AHEAD ESTABLISH. PLEASE
CALL RICARDO. HER TITLE HERE
STONE STONE HERE BELL BILL HERE
JACKSON PAN PAN HERE WIENER.
FOR OKAY GREAT. SO WE DON'T
GREAT SO WE HAVE A MOTION TO
MOVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THE
MOTION IS AFFRONT TO BE ADOPTED
AS AMENDED. US SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. I RICARDO AYE
STONE STONE I KNOW. BELL I
JACKSON PAN PAN AYE WIENER WE
HAVE FOUR. SO WE HAVE THE BILL
IS FOR AND WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
LEAVE THE ROLE OPENED TO ALLOW
OTHER MEMBERS. OPTION ABOUT.
THANK YOU FOR THAT
. THE ROLE.
JACKSON. JACKSON I JACKSON AYE
WIENER. FIVE ZERO THE VOTE IS
FIVE ZERO WILL CONTINUE TO
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
. NUMBER TWO.
YEAH SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND OPEN
UP THE ROLE ON A TO YOUR
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ARE FOURTEEN
LACKEY THE MOTION IS THE
ADOPTED AS AMENDED WITH
RECOMMENDATION TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WIENER WIENER HIGH SIX
VOTES SO THE VOTE IS SIX ZERO
WE WILL GO AHEAD AND NOW CLOSER
ROLE THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND
THIS AND ARMY TO PROTECT